Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau wo ich das hingelegt habe aber ich wäre jederzeit bereit aufzustehen meine Hände aus der Tasche zu nehmen und zu schwören ist zu beschützen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 272 vom 19. Oktober 2018.
Da sitzen wir.
Tim ich begrüße Dich in diesem schönen Land.
Ja das ist schön danke.
Seit wann.
Sag seit gestern mit der Aushändigung der Urkunde ist es sozusagen vollzogen,
die Urkunde war 2017.
Musstest du dahin.
Park 0 und für die Leute die es immer noch nicht wissen was a die Phase ist ich habe sozusagen,
brexit vollzogen,
im guten Timing werden diese parallel irgendwie die ganzen brexit Gespräche so richtig schön vor die Hunde geraten so,
nicht dass ich dich jemals schon mal einen besseren Zustand befunden hätten auf als die Zeit läuft halt dann doch ab ja ist mir der Absprung gedungen und Bürger der Bundesrepublik deutsch.
Rübergemacht Westen Osten.
Bis zum 1.
Luft in den Osten.
Kannst du uns kannst du uns bitte mal deine Einbürgerungsurkunde zeigen lieber Tim.
Ja doch schon und.
Sende wenn du die SuS begrüßt sich schon mal unseren Gast Frank Rieger.
Noch mal hallo genau wir uns mit dem Frank dazugeholt um.
Um hier mal anzustoßen.
Ist Hofmann mit einem Gläschen waterforce Nachteile.
So Einbürgerungsurkunde geboren in Gürtel das ist aber nicht England ne.
Nee ist deutschlands.
Und ich finde ja tatsächlich dass sie das hätten war durchaus ein bisschen feierlicher gestalten können dieses Dokument.
Achso okay das ist spricht spricht die Wahrheit.
Es wird sind es wird einfach sehr deutschen alles hat irgendwie so eine keine Schnörkel.
Wenn du das Ding irgendwo verlegt,
das ist meine Einführung socle würde jeder sagt Deutschland in jedem anderen Land hätte man wenigstens irgendwie ein.
Wappen mit bisschen Schnörkel und Goldrand unten Drehgestell.
Scheiße aussehen aber es durchaus glaube ich eine sehr beliebte Renault Kunden Diva,
auf diesem Planeten erwerben kann,
auf jeden Fall aber jetzt nicht auf E-Mail packen aber ist halt so an sich schon mal ganz okay na ich meine ich muss also auf der einen Seite bin ich jetzt irgendwie nicht nennenswert bewegt weil,
für mich war ich schon immer SMS erinnert sich nicht,
Basis ist ein rein formaler Akt dass ich auch weiterhin EU-Bürger Rechte genießen darf das eigentlich.
Wobei davon steht da ja nichts erstmal ne.
Steht da nicht aber das ist sauer mal das Ding weil meine Verbundenheit mit dieser Kultur hier
muss ich glaube nicht weiter darlegen soll ich meine ich habe schon immer in Deutschland gewohnt und habe ich halt einfach auch dadurch immer so als Europäer gesehen,
also das war für mich immer schon so vollkommen normal wollen sie in gewisser Hinsicht auch hilfreich weil ich eigentlich nie in dieser Versuchung stand mir jetzt auf deutsch zu irgendwie fiel ein zu bilden.
Das wird sich jetzt ändern das kommt mit der Urkunde,
Tim Pritlove hat mit dem Zeitpunkt der Aushändigung dieser Urkunde deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft durch Einbürgerung erworben.
Angehörigkeit staatsangeh.
Staatsangehörigkeit durch Einbürgerung erworben die Einbürgerung hat sich nicht auf Kinder des der eingebürgerten erstreckt ja das ist also so und feierlich gestaltet,
und das dann noch nicht mal irgendwie ne man sagt ok wenn das des eingebürgerten oder der eingebürgert nur dass unterscheiden wir hier in der oder das man da mal mit der Schreibmaschine über das falsche Wort geht und nix drüber macht oder so eine so und feierliche.
Na ja die ist halt so ausgelegt dass man ja nicht viel drin tun muss für die korrekte Ausfüllung deshalb ist es heute sozusagen Massen fähig.
Die ist Massen fertig.
1 Millionen müssen jetzt hier noch durch diesen Prozess gebre.
Herrgott wie viel waren es nicht mehr wie viele Schicksals genossen hast du da irgendwie gefunden ritten die weg wollen und unten DeutschlandSIM.
Spiele also ich war ja neulich weicher meiner britischen Botschaft aus einer brexit Infoveranstaltung.
Die machen sowas.
Eigentlich nicht weil das war tatsächlich angeregt von so einer Initiative British people in Europe und wieso
Amazon Europe die halt auch absolut gegen brexit sind eigentlich im Kern und die dann halt in der Botschaft quasi,
zusammengetrommelt haben da sprach da noch jemand von der Botschaft und die Leute können.
Du merkst du richtig wenn die Mund aufmachen die haben überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf,
aber sie wissen dass sie da Jan eitel geleistet haben das was die Regierung sagt ist das was sie dazu vermitteln habe nicht mehr das ist so ein bisschen die Diplomaten
Problematik nasowas warmbier,
eigentlich ein interessantes Leben aber manchmal kommt halt auch nur scheiße dabei raus was du da vertreten musst,
saßen Hilflosigkeit versuchte er dann halt so Neuigkeiten zu verteilen wie es denn so steht mit dem brexit,
wird halt im Wesentlichen eigentlich gar nicht sagen so so nach dem Motto naja also will die Verhandlungen gehen ja irgendwie vorhanden und es ist ja auch das ein oder andere wurde auch schon besprochen wann kann man schon so ein erfrage naja aber irgendwie wenn am Ende nichts beschloss
wird alles gar nichts davon ja nee dann halt nichts.
Dann gute Gespräche geführt und.
Ja so also es war wirklich schon schlimm und dann drehte sich zu dir da mal so 150 Leute und die haben alle so ja fragen gefragt dann am Anfang,
ging die dritten die Fragen sich noch so ein bisschen um das was du ursprünglich jetzt mal so als informations Häppchen auf dem Tisch gelegt wurde,
gib dir dann aber sehr schnell und so nach 20-30 Minuten,
war das eine Phase von der halben Stunde muss ich nur noch ein einziges Thema im Raum gar,
windig Was muss man eigentlich machen um deutscher Staatsbürger zu werden,
in der britischen Botschaft mit Briten das hätte ich im Traum nicht für möglich gehalten aber,
ja dann musst du doch das Dokument haben und so habe ich auch gemacht,
Exodus Stimmung deluxe,
und dass das war in sich schon erschrecken und besonders erschreckt waren so Leute die so experts sind,
möchtest du richtig den war so Brite sein echt wichtig so,
nein verlagert sich dann irgendwann so dieses Gefühl ja was ist denn wenn ich dann deutscher bin darf ich denn dann überhaupt noch zurück,
und so also auch zum Heulen teilweise schon fast merkt das wie die Leute so vollkommen,
einfach so das Unglück auf sich zurollen sahen und nicht wussten.
Sie tun sollen so und ich stand da halt dachte mir so um tut mir echt leid für euch ich weiß nur,
bei mir ist jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch eine Frage von ein paar Monaten und jetzt wird das halt durch,
aber bei dem Sport den man jetzt gerne über das Land,
ausschütten möchte nie sicherlich auch verdient haben,
musst halt sagen es gibt da halt auch 48% die haben dagegen gestimmt und das sind irgendwie viele Millionen Leute und eigentlich mittlerweile noch mehr weil viele jetzt überhaupt erst verstanden haben was sie da er nicht getan haben,
die einfach mal vor dem Abgrund stehen so und gerade wenn es halt jetzt auf wirklich wenn es für dich auf dem Note dir hinausläuft dann,
ja dann haben wir da irgendwie so ein stolzes Land mit 56 Millionen Leute völlig verstört,
das wird ein Spaß.
Der Anwesenheit dieser Insel in Europa und wie,
stabile Verhältnisse in Europa sicherzustellen weil die werden natürlich dann auch nach jedem Strohhalm greifen,
Ausweg bieten möchte auch wenn das alles nicht funktionieren wird aber,
wird nicht lustig für uns deswegen blicke ich halt auf die aktuellen Verhandlung Linien auch somit,
na gewissen Bohnen ruhigen weil auf der einen Seite sehe ich ganz klar dass die Position der EU absolut vertretbar ist die sagen halt einfach so,
Hallo wer zählt seit 2 Jahren gleiche und daran hat sich jetzt auch nichts geändert und hier sind unsere Prinzipien und die halten jetzt auch durch,
so andererseits die Unfähigkeit,
die einen wollten irgendwie den anderen Teil,
Schlüsselbox vernichten wurde aus Raum und die anderen sind irgendwie dagegen oder was man wie die Sache steht aber Großbritannien ist einfach total Hühnerhaufen da weiß einfach keiner so richtig mir wohin er will,
das ist würdig shocking und mal gucken also,
bringt die EU setzt derzeit einfach da drauf dass irgendwas.
Das irgendwas Umfallen wird und und sie sich auf so ein peoples Wort einigen und dann denke ich,
Lucia Mense angedackelt kommen sagen weil es nur Spaß dürfen wir wieder mitspielen so und dann wird die Ursachen hier so ja aber.
Keine special deals.
Und dann würde halt das ein oder andere wird dann halt gekillt werde ich denke nicht dass sie ihn dann um mir noch den Euro in den Schlund drücken wollen aber,
dann können Sie auch sehr glücklich sein nur the damages bin dann also Großbritannien wird sich von dem diplomatischen Desaster so schnell nicht erholen also das ist für die nächsten 10 Jahre,
stehen sie wirklich davidii totalen Affen und die Leute die das schon verstanden haben oder schon immer verstanden haben.
Gibt so die wussten das schon immer und der der Rest dem wird das wahrscheinlich auch erst schrittweise klar na ja egal also ich bin jetzt irgendwie raus aus der Problematik aus der unmittelbar nicht wert trotzdem das jetzt weiter verfolgen was hier Sache ist.
Hund aber herzlich willkommen Tim.
Genau willkommen an Bord.
Ich darf jetzt wählen.
Oh nein.
Ich habe mir auch schon einen Bundestagsabgeordneten hier der für das Gebiet zuständig ist getroffen und.
Guten Tag ich bin ihr neuwähler.
Ich bin neu Villa ich möchte mich jetzt hier mit ein.
Ich muss noch mal gucken was muss man eigentlich jetzt Kanzler werden will was brauche ich da irgendwelche.
Guten Tag der der Bezirk heißt nicht mehr Pankow sondern,
und hier sind meine feature requests.
No border sozial.
Ich habe auch was mitgebracht.
Und fahren habe ich ja schon vor mehreren Folgen Vollmond nicht angekündigt dass der Christian und ich Podcast Geschichte schreiben während des habe auch getan und zwar haben wir eine.
Kleiner geht's nicht mehr.
Ist der Tatsache der erste und letzte Podcast aus dem aus einer Kohlen,
Mine im Ruhrpott wir sind eingefahren auf
Prosper auf 1200 m Tiefe ins Abbaugebiet und haben dort vor der Kohle gestanden habe ich einen schönes Foto davon wie die mit der,
wie heißt das Ding Schreiben Walzel da lang.
Die Fachbegriffe muss jetzt schon wissen.
Ja der walzenschrämlader,
Bernd das ist also ein riesiges eine riesige riesige,
Metall Ding was also dann durch den Fluss fährt und da die die Kohle.
Die Dinosaurier aus Krepp.
Die Dinosaurier aus gräbt genau und das war so.
Ja klar dass dass uns ja allan klar dass der Kohlenbergbau,
leben mit dem Jahr 2018 enden wird,
in dem Fall war es aber so dass quasi eine Woche später die ihre Fördermenge hatten und damit
auch wirklich der Kohlenbergbau im Ruhrgebiet zum Ende gekommen ist etwas frühzeitig das heißt wir waren noch so mit
die letzten die es geschafft haben da eine Gruppenfahrt zu machen und haben das ganze sehr ausführlich und aufwendig dokumentiert indem,
Kohlenpott,
Nummer 12 Vorort auf Zeche Prosper Haniel der natürlich auch in den Shownotes verlinkt ist das ist so eine dauert zweieinhalb Stunden ungefähr und
wir haben ja ja auch unter Extrembedingungen ge Podcaster denn da unten darfst du nicht Podcasten ist ja alles voller Kohle und Grubengas
das heißt die haben aus gegebenem Anlass große Sorge dass sie in der ganze Laden der um die Ohren fliegt weshalb,
dort brauchen und alle möglichen elektronische Geräte,
Kamera Handy und so weiter alles verboten ist du musst quasi zugelassene explosionsgeschützte Geräte haben um darunter zu gehen.
Deswegen hatten wir einen explosionsgeschütztes Diktiergerät Baujahr 1989,
von der eben technisch abgenommen warum dort unten betrieben,
werden zu dürfen und das entsprechend ist auch die Aufnahmequalität,
mitunter solange wir mit der dieselkatze fahren dass es die,
hier dieses geniale Teil aber auch ein schönes Bild davon des sitzpferd also an der an der Decke hängend an so Stahlträgern mit Diesel betrieben hatten paar Anhänger hinten dran da sitzen dann die Leute drin,
da ist der Slider akustisch eine Herausforderung diese,
Deezer Podcast würde ich vielleicht nicht mit Kopfhörern hören und man kann aber auch die Katzen Fahrt überspringen und sich dann,
anhören wie es eben da unten klingt.
Aber keine Kapitel Mar.
Bitte mich verscherzen ich habe einen Tag 56 Kapitelmarken in dem Ding gesetzt.
Dein Player ist Cup.
Nee dann wird der Player zeigt sie nicht an geht aber auf deinen Link.
Na weil er wahrscheinlich standardmäßig mp3 hat oder so aber das.
Ja dann kannst du mal technische Beratung zukommen lassen das Ding hat auf jeden Fall Kapitelmarken.
Das schön wenn man Portugals Geschichte schreibt das muss mal.
Podcast Geschichte ohne Kapitelmarken was wäre was wäre Podcast Geschichte oder Köpfe ich guck mal ganz kurz.
Snow oder Kapitel Makis geht auch.
Ich schaue mal Geld aber das wäre jetzt geöffnet.
Gibt es doch.
Legacy Podcast.
Ein Streit Grund.
Siehdichum skippen es geht um zurückspulen und direkt noch mal hören.
Neuer Player ist kaputt also ich gucke mal hier ganz kurz Kohlenpott 12 play.
Hier Thermax ohne Ende.
Der Jacke in der Datei aber ihr habt sie halten.
Ja da musst du musst du halt mal hier ein bisschen, sogar chapter marks mit Bildern ja also wenn man die voll gehört komm oben die Bilder die da fotografiert von jetzt wird es natürlich jeder fragen wie habt ihr denn eine Kamera da runtergebracht der Fotograf,
hatte eine Leica also so eine.
Analoge filmmaker.
Die analogen Film Lycana mit dem wie heißt noch mal dieses System als du du,
Besucher ja da hast du nämlich in dem Sucher,
keine Spiele Flag sondern in dem Sucher stellst du auch quasi
wenn du an der wenn du an dem Objektiv drehst
verstehst du auch am suche etwas in müssen zwei kleine Bilder übereinander sein dass er sie einmal das große Bild und in der Mitte noch mal ein kleines,
und da wo diese Dinger übereinander sind da stellst Du scharf und das Spannende an diesem leihkasse ist dass sie dadurch dass sie eben,
nicht diese die Nachteile einer Spiegelreflexkamera haben insbesonder endlich die Lichtstärke und objektive schon damals hatten also Leica Objektive sind ja,
bekannt eigentlich als die besten die du so kriegst die Leica Kameras kosteten glaube ich auch immer.
Es ist immer Investitionsgüter an gewesen.
Sommerferien Kleinwagen und entsprechen sie da eben auch die Bilder entstanden mit sehr abgehangener,
Technologie explosionsgeschützte Leica und der Fotograf hatte einen explosionsgeschützten blitz um die Schulter hängt das war dann ungefähr so groß wie,
ja also ein ein sehr sehr großes Teil was du,
dass ihm dann da blitzte und hat absolut abgedichtet war der mit der Funke den dieser Blitz macht eben nicht dafür sorgt dass dir diese der gesamte dafür normalen Grubenunglück kurz vor vor Ende machst ne.
Samsung Abgang mit zombey ne.
Das also es ist äußerst äußerst spannend und ich freue mich dass wir dieses diese Erfahrung noch mal ein bisschen teilen konnten deswegen,
hier ist das hiermit ans Herz gelegt und dass der podlove Webplayer die chaptermark nicht.
Na gut löschen.
Das sind ja die Dinge die Leute dann wirklich bewegen ob es denn jetzt de kicsoda de six heißt also.
Was würdest du sagen den Keks oder DCs.
Notiz ich schon immer.
Und gib oder Jeff.
Dyson Slim ich auch so dass der Erfinder selber ist falsch ausspricht.
Ist ganz klar.
Also es wird darauf hingewiesen dass es ja die Abkürzung ist für commercial Internet exchange und Manni,
commercial ausspricht und von der Kickz wäre uns gibt wohl auch Interviews mit Wie Vertretern.
Sollte die giftig sein sollen auch Kina oder Kimi.
Genau oder.
So Leute ne.
Ja gestern gab es auch ein.
Ich spreche halt die Abkürzung so aus wie sie,
als Abkürzung rüberkommt so und da steht dann halt ce&ce ist für mich halt dann soft,
so und da kann man jetzt lange drüber diskutieren welcher dieser beiden Ansätze richtig ist oder nicht.
Mailroom nach wenn von fixen die Rede ist und das,
der nicht nur das de six sondern es gibt ja viele Zitzen sagt jeder eilig zum Sixpacks und nicht Keks oder,
und deswegen ist es de six verdammt noch mal kommen wir zu etwas wichtige drin.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen das wahrscheinlich der Punkt indem er wieder für diese Sendung am meisten Feedback.
Ist der Rest ist egal da geht ja noch die Welt.
Mit Sicherheit.
Alle alle wie alt versus eMac Diskussion sind ja.
So einen weiteren heißt es natürlich.
Ja natürlich milch.
Weil es irgendwie graphical interchange Format ist ne und nicht graphical oder war das richtig was.
Wie heißt könnte man natürlich argumentieren dass unsere Logik sich hier auf den Kopf stellt so.
Nee weil wir nicht von dem eigentlichen also der Britta wird ja auch.
Graphic ist nicht soft & commercial auch nicht.
Spedition Sachsen fragt commercial.
Achso scheiße okay lassen wir das dafür das heißt give und Keks.
Jan verstehst Du genau.
Siphon.
Verrücktes Ausflugsziel Tier.
Du wir müssen hier bis in die Kommentare befeuern.
Jascha beschäftigen wir uns lieber mit anderen drei Buchstaben Abkürzung hier in diesem Wochenende,
versuchten zu spielen.
Kinder GPS Uhr.
CSU hat FC Prozent stimmen in Bayern verloren.
Ja also die Aufregung die um diese Bayern wahr gemacht wurde kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Also was passiert TV hat 10% 10% verloren ADAC Prozent gewonnen,
19% ging irgendwie auch an die Freien Wähler ihr war auch schon vorher irgendwie hat man nämlich 10% dazugewonnen bisschen was oder so nah
grüner für abgeräumt aber ich sehe halt nicht dass es da große Verschiebungen Zwischensummen rechts links Lager gab wenn man sowas überhaupt.
Machen möchte.
Na ja so der interessante. War ja eigentlich dass die Leute,
kein Bock mehr darauf hatten dieselbe Kleptokratie da in Bayern weiter zu befördern und deswegen hat lieber sich ein paar neue Kleptokraten von der Freien Wähler geholt haben.
Aber sonst hat keine große Politik Änderung ich habe ja im Rahmen von diesem Bayern weiding,
ein bisschen recherchiert was damals in Bayern so früher los war,
zur seine Chronik des Bayerischen Landtages so viele hundert Seiten.
Und auch über die sich da so damals zu gestritten haben wenn es aus heutiger passt,
sie betrachten nur so sagen diesen Parlament saßen nur Nazis nur weil die Hand,
Parlamentsmehrheit Theaterstücke irgendwie abgesetzt die haben diese Renzel Bayern so in den,
Ende der 40er bis weit in die 50er rein drehte sich nur um die Flüchtlingsfrage,
kinox.to Flüchtlingslager sie vergeht die Leute die aus Polen raus mussten und Ostpreußen und so sind ja viele nach Bayern gegangen viele die aus aus Deutschland geflohen sind auf viele nach Bayern gegangen,
und die Bayern wollten ich nicht in den ganzen richtigen harten Religionskonflikt zwischen Protestanten und Katholiken.
Dann hat die CSU bei einer Wahl,
die hilft ihre Stimmen verloren,
die Bayernpartei zu dem Zeitpunkt so einen harten,
wir wollen ja nicht noch mehr Flüchtlinge irgendwie Bayern ist katholisch hier geht mal alle weg und lass uns in Ruhe Kurs gefahren hat und damit und die.
Wichtiger ist das wichtige Thema war die Zustimmung Bayerns zum.
Die CSU hat heute zum Dinge fangen gesagt,
bestimmt im Grundgesetz nicht zu weil wir gehen halt zuviel Macht nach Bonn,
aber wenn die Zweidrittelmehrheit zustande kommt der Länder dann akzeptieren wir dass es halt so ist ohne,
und es war in der Bayernpartei nicht radikal wenn noch so ein wenn du jetzt nicht so erziehe diese die wollten halt so Bayern bleibt Bayern Freistaat und und wieso hat so halt Monarchisten schon Sonne,
also würdest du liest oder Geschichte durch das ganz interessant zu meinem wie so ein bisschen so diese kulturpolitische Kultur von Bayern zu verstehen ist wirklich toll anders ausfällt.
Könnte aber verliebt ist wirklich ganz interessant.
Also die die CSU hat je nachdem aber jetzt erst oder Zweitstimme anschaut so um die 10% verloren der SPD über 10%,
gewonnen haben,
die Grünen 8,9 % und also wie gesagt immer Unterschiede große Unterschiede hinterm Komma zwischen erst und Zweitstimmen AFD,
10 % weil sie eben vorher nicht da war ja der war vorbei,
0 oder unter der Grenze,
Freie Wähler haben 2% gewonnen FDP hat 2% geworden Linkert ein Prozent gewonnen bleibt aber weiterhin unter 5.
Fand das sehr schön das zeigt er auch so diese diese Kultur als dann der,
Markus Söder am Wahlabend vor die Kamera straat unseren I stay,
wird nach der Wahl war dann so ja also nach so einem,
Wahlergebnis muss man ja auch Verantwortung übernehmen und ich dachte das gibt's doch nicht devitto jetzt nicht die Verantwortung übernehmen und dann sagt er so und ja die CSU würde jetzt eben die Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen,
zeigte aber die haben das dass sie das Ding über die Bühne gehen lassen würden ohne den Söder oder den Seehofer,
war zu erwarten ich hätte halt nur nicht gedacht wiwiwi butterweich das geht ne,
das sieht das also dass es diese Kultur des Rücktritts die ist irgendwie.
Ich meine letzten Endes ist halt dieses Jumping so von wegen so wenn müsste mich schon mit einem Studium beim Schule raustragen Ding hat sich,
da als neuen Standard etabliert sondern so nachdem nach Wulfen,
Gutenberg warst Du die letzten waren die halt noch wegen Verfehlungen gegangen sind.
Beruf kann man darüber debattieren aber falls die tatsächlich sozusagen nach einer öffentlichen Debatte gegangen sind hat sich das eigentlich nicht mehr so also als ist eigentlich ausziehen angesagt ne also ich war das hängt halt.
Also überall auf allen Ebenen an so selbst in die Parteien treten die Leute in nur noch zurück eigentlich weil Ines zu nervig wird von ihren Ämtern,
hat keinen Bock auf Diskussionen haben aber nicht weil irgendwie sie jetzt sind wir sich da in Verantwortung fühlen soll.
Das ist insofern wirklich dramatisch war ja,
and also entweder Skandale zwischen den Wahlen oder ebendiese Wahlergebnis ja die eine,
die eine Möglichkeit sind er überhaupt einen zu wirken ja und wenn.
Dann nur noch die letzte also ich meine ist halt so dass ich dass diese Rücktritts das keinen,
Kultur wie du sagst mir gibt ist der das Problem dass die.
Ja Änderung des politischen Systems oder die Änderung von politischer Verantwortung,
zwischen den Wahlen hat immer schwieriger und unmöglich oder worden ist und halt auch dieses envy,
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen also Maßen zum Schluss ein schönes Beispiel dafür Nase Maßen ist halt so ein klares Ding von der Typ müsste eigentlich mal für das was er getan hat zur Verantwortung gezogen werden zumindestens dadurch dass man ihn entfernt aus irgendwie den höchsten diesen Positionen
aber Signal von Seehofer ist ne alles gut ne der bleibt jetzt so und ist nicht laut.
So ist immer noch Chef.
Na das bis zum bis jemanden Nachfolger für infinite ne das kann dauern und die ich glaube das ist halt so eine,
wir sind jetzt hier und die machen sie jetzt hier bequem das geht auch wiederum gerade so die AFD hart befeuern wird so weiter wenn eine Menge Leute denken nicht zu Unrecht denken soll Hey die sind da wirklich nur noch korrupter um.
Das ist wirklich das ist das was ich da so,
im dancing finden was hat der Schaden im Jahr auch weil ich würde niemals die CSU überhaupt wählen können es sei denn ich kriege auch so eine Urkunde wieder Tim für den Freistaat Bayern aber,
Gabber dass ich auch dann wahrscheinlich nicht die CSU wählen würde insofern ist.
Zu beeindrucken voraussetzt.
Beschwerden Sie auf das Parteiprogramm der CSU.
Sofern ist jetzt ja eigentlich erstmal könnte ich mich ja freuen wenn diese Partei 10% Wählerstimmen verliert aber,
diese diese Kultur das ist das was wir wirklich Sorgen macht weil ich denke damit betreiben die ebenso wie die SPD mit dieser Aktion mit dieser Martin Schulz Aktion,
niemals groko hast du nicht gesehen ich werde auch zumindest so her damit richten diese so ein,
Schaden an ein Flurschaden über alle Parteien im Prinzipien weg weil es das Vertrauen in überhaupt diese,
diesen Demokratie Wahl und sonst was process halt,
maximal schlecht und stört und das ist das was so.
Was soll ich wirklich schockierend ist daran.
Hab hier gerade den Einbürgerungstest die Fragen aus Bayern online gefunden und Frage 2.
Ein Bonusheft für was.
Also nach Deutschland in Bayern.
Aber die der Bayern Modus,
und lustigerweise ist der Gips eines den Fragen,
was ist richtig sind in Deutschland Religionsgemeinschaften und der Staat getrennt Antwort ja sind getrennt ist richtig,
irgendwie müssen ihren eigenen Änderungs das Vergessen Haar verzierter super Kreuz behindert.
Einbürgerungstest online Acacia online mach.
Bekommt ein Kind was muss ich tun um Elterngeld zu erhalten echt das ist der Eignungstest.
Na das musst du musst mal auf sehr schwer schalten dann wird interessanter an dann hast du das jetzt.
Sie muss einen Anhang bei der Elterngeldstelle.
Berlin geht einfach so.
Nee ich bin halt ja schon.
Mit welchen Worten beginnt die deutsche Nationalhymne Völker hört die Signale.
Ich weiß ich will lösen auferstanden aus Ruinen.
Das war die Kommunisten rausfiltern.
Dann hätten wir ein Sendungstitel.
Können wir ja weiß nicht,
kann man dazu noch sagen eigentlich ist nichts passiert Kultur im Arsch.
SPD hat noch 9,7 % ist alles gut.
Ja
Sind ne Parlament Mainz.
Ja also meine alle halten natürlich jetzt noch die Füße still war jetzt noch Hessen kommt das hat sich dieses Wochenende schon mal gucken ne.
Da wird Thorsten Schäfer-Gümbel wird für die SPD dann riecht.
Villa richten ja wobei grünes mittlerweile glaube ich auch schon wieder im Boot also weiß.
Superdimension hinrichten oder also ich meine.
Wir schauen uns das an mit deine Meinung aber geht mal wählen.
Ja wählen den dass du jeden Fall trotzdem eigentlich an.
Ja die Partei hat auch in,
den einzelnen Gemeinden ganz gute Ergebnisse erzielt was ich bemerkenswert finde,
verliert und,
insbesondere in München also das hätte glaube ich auch keiner geglaubt vor einigen Jahren dass die Grünen mal wie viel Türken sitzt.
10 Cent.
Nee aber Bezirk am durchweg Direktmandat oder Siege.
Direktmandate genau ne also von irgendwie 12 oder sowas bist schon du schon,
das ist schon bemerkenswert und zeigt aber auch dass sich das linke,
Warum zumindest vorübergehend an assortiert und dass die SPD damit relativ wenig zu tun hat.
Also die haben wirklich so ihr links Ding doch extrem eingebüßt bin ich wach.
So Frank aber Dich haben ja eigentlich jetzt hier nicht rein geholt um hier Tagespolitik zu diskutieren seine bisher auch eher Abteilung Grundsatzfragen.
Und immer der beste Anlass,
für ein Interview hast ein Buch,
herausgebracht gemeinsam mit Constanze Kurz als ich rausgebracht hat geschrieben,
seid ihr Autoren sein wievieltes Buch ist denn das jetzt eigentlich bist ja schon richtig.
Dazu müssen Wikipedia Kriterien III I war datenfresser über Datenschutz und privacy II arbeitsfreie über Automatisierung,
Übersäuerung.
Wie viel Buch muss man schreiben bis man Schriftsteller wird.
Ich glaube Schriftsteller zählt als wenn man davon leben kann geliebtes gelegt nur selten.
Meinst du gibt nicht so viele von dem.
Nee das ist er also ja klar gut dass man könnte sich jetzt als Schriftsteller Witze,
aber besser wir etwas eingeengt.
Ja alles sehr aktivistische Themen was hat euch denn so dazu gebracht das Thema.
Nee wir haben also eine damit angefangen letzten Herbst dort immer so eine Weile bis zum Buch dann geschrieben ist und raus ist und
da war halt ja schon absehbar dass diese Diskussionen darüber wie sich Deutschland zu diesem ganzen Themenkomplex positioniert wie viel,
offensiv Kapazitäten in welcher Behörde aufgebaut werden
der Staat jetzt anfangen soll im Rahmen seiner Staatstrojaner Programme explodes zu entwickeln und aufzukaufen dass diese Diskussion halte immer wichtiger und immer größer wird und wir hatten da so ein bisschen essbedürfnis mal.
Jan in einer gewissen kondensierten Form Stellung zu beziehen die auch ein Tag vor einigen viele Sachen erläutert weil wir finden Diskussionen gerade in der Politik über auch so mit den Unternehmen und so immer wieder feststellen dass viele Sachen einfach sehr unklar sind was,
nur die Basics angeht also sowas wie,
Wie funktioniert eigentlich eine Sicherheitslücke wie nutzt man Sicherheitslücke aus wie funktionieren Exploit,
was ist eigentlich ein Buffer Overflow einfach mal so zu erklären dass ist die verständlich ist und verständlich,
so für Leute die einfach keinen technischen Hintergrund haben und dann daraus abzuleiten halt doch die,
die Frage wie gehen wir damit um,
was sind die die Mechanismen die auf der strategischen Ebene passieren also wie immer Hansi stark gegenseitig wie,
online bist ganzes halber wird man in der Sonne liegt die gesamte Weltpolitik und so
das war so ein bisschen so der,
ja der Hintergrund dabei also zu versuchen denen das Thema,
allgemein verständlich aufzubereiten dass man eine politische Diskussion darüber führen kann.
Und wie geht man daran also was.
Wenn's geht das ob das alles so aus eurem Kopf voraus oder hast du dich Recherche mit verbunden.
Laspeyres also die gut wir sind in dem Thema schon relativ lange unterwegs hat sie auch Afrikaner Sendung so die anzahl,
damit umgeht in diversen Trojanern und so dass er nun jetzt nichts nichts Neues.
Wir haben können valinos.
Natürlich haben wir aber nicht.
Ja also das halt so ein natürlich zu meinem Thema drin sein hilft halt schon zum anderen haben wir dann noch vertiefen mit Leuten geredet die,
in dem Feld unterwegs und hat sich auf allen möglichen Seiten also,
auch mit Leuten auf der Darkseid die heute,
dann bei diversen westlichen Staaten hatte in den Schützengräben sind,
um halt einfach die ja auch ein bisschen so first hinzuhören was ein,
passiert und wie denken richtig viel Wasser zum wieso die strategische Diskussionen angeht,
gibt's ja auch zu lesen ist heute nur ein bisschen anstrengen weil muss halt ziemlich viel papers von sofort Regen Konferenzen lesen wo sich die die Meinung in der strategischen,
ja die man sich auch Community da herausbildet also wie die hat dann sonnen,
dansommer Auseinandersetzung rangehen und was auch noch aktiv pro total sind die Forderungen,
die war am Ende haben sie wollen sie mich immer so ein bisschen pädagogisch auf nasse Frauen erstmal klären,
was ist Problem und dann wieso haben wir das Problem und dann was kann man dagegen tun.
Andy warum sind eigentlich Sachen die Wette Sendung zum Tauschen diskutiert haben wo wir versuchen halt das ganze ein bisschen,
umzubringen solltest du die Sachen die man mal machen müssen.
Ausschlag politin Pfählung.
Deshalb sonst sowas nicht machen also ist halt doch alles andere ist langweilig es geht halt primär darum.
Und denkst du das S4 von Politikern gekauft und gelesen.
Also interessanterweise ist das Feedback gerade sehr vielen Wirtschaft gekauft und gelesen oder das was halt also gerade so in,
kannst du einfach stehen und so die also was ich so ein Feedback bekomme aus solchen kreisen ihr so eine hnt für uns noch mal dieses erklärt ohne Bullshit,
so besonders ja auch die Rollos Club halt einfach Sachen zu erklären,
ohne hat Commerz Bullshit da dran ohne dass man halt irgendwie wieder nur die nächste Feier wurde oder erst nächste intrusion detection system verkaufen bist einfach erklären sie Problem ist und was hat Meter Lösung dafür wer sein könnten sind,
dafür ist halt schon ein relativ großer ja große Reaktionen große Empfänglichkeit auch da und Diesel.
Diese Methode hat ein paar Sachen,
gut zu erklären und daraus Forderung abzuleiten hat sich aus unserer Sicht auf dort sehr bewährt wenn man halt versuchen will Thema auseinander Perspektiven Diskussion zu bringen die jetzt eben nicht,
den Leuten die jetzt an ja wir brauchen unbedingt mir offensiv Kapazitäten und wir müssen und wir müssen den bis 14 Uhr über lassen sondern,
bisschen rationaler ranzugehen und irgendwie bisschen,
ja einfach ja Leitung zu machen und nicht nur zur Post Ohle.
Es war natürlich nicht das ganze Buch nacherzählen und Buchlesung machen aber,
wieso da auch eure aus als auf was findet Definition ja eigentlich gekommen seid also vor allem Cyberwar,
ist ja jetzt auch so ein Wort was erstmal so dem normalen war was hinzufügt,
seht ihr das getan als einen separates Ereignis oder geht's,
um Krieg an sich.
Es ist tatsächlich eine Erweiterung der
das muss man in allen anderen Feldern der Auseinandersetzung zwischen Staaten sehen,
kriege sie wer sie früher gekannt haben sag mal so den
die leichte romantisierte Auseinandersetzung nach der Haager Landkriegsordnung,
muss ich am ihnen gegenüber stehen die Klauen die Form haben,
Klaus Schlachtfeld da ist und zum Wien davor und danach,
und wo sollen wir einen Krieg gibt und danach und wir eine Friedensordnung das haben wir halt nicht mehr also es halt so dass die,
die Auseinandersetzung wird auch außerhalb des digitalen Raum stattfinden,
in der Regel schon sehr stark konfus sind was wir sind nicht damit zu tun hat dass die Mittel und Methoden der Geheimdienste,
im militärischen Bereich angekommen sind also die,
die Fragen die wir zur Schmidt Syrien sehen sind halt.
Länder fordern irgendwelche Milizen oder welche Stämme oder Clans,
einfache ihre Kampfkraft im höchsten wieder zur Verfügung stellen haben die eine politische Interessen an der ergonomische Interessen,
treten die getarnt auf ganz viel von dem was heute passiert in Kriegführung es ja so special forces Operationen wo er soll,
undeklariert sowas Sendetermine der Krim gesehen haben diese kleinen grünen Männchen,
mit denen Putin hat die Krim robert hat Waldman klassisches Beispiel für wie heute kriege aussehen also das Wetter wie,
erstmal psychologischer Einfluss Operation,
Zerrüttung wie der der Meinung verorten ist halt nach und nach Rieste halt die.
Ja das Aktions Level hoch und bist du dann halt am Ende bei einer medizinischen Besetzung bis das war quasi so Bilderbuch,
Exekution von sowas und wenn es dagegen aber merkt und halt wiederum andersrum also genauso agiert dann kommt halt sowas wie was gerade im Donbass haben raus also halt einfach so,
und die karierte Gruppen ukrainische Nazis ukrainische Regierung straw,
russische Freiwillige in Anführungszeichen die dann wieder im Wesentlichen vom FSP finanziert werden,
aber auch von amtlichen russischen Oligarchen und sucht ich weiß was eigentlich nicht und dann gibt's wieder dran die trotzdem Waffenhandel miteinander
und machen irgendwelche Dielsdorf irgendwelche Bus,
gegenseitig Gebiete überlassen oder auch nicht und so und um sich dann am nächsten Tag wieder zu beschießen.
Aber so richtig neu ist das jetzt auch nicht mehr so sicher Begriff Stellvertreterkriege der hatten wir schon im
Kalten Krieg der wurde sie einmal um den ganzen Globus herum überall irgendwo das Ost gegen West Ding ausgespielt und Alt auf da in Südostasien Korea ca überall war das ja inwiefern ist es jetzt anders.
Na alles ist dass es nur noch sowas gibt
was gefällt der dir Modus des Krieges ist halt irgendwas in NRW eigentlich seit Ende der 60er halt als diese gereja Kriege der Stellvertreterkriege sich etabliert hatte
nur das total in der Regel und noch relativ klare Strukturen waren also halt irgendwie die vietnamesische Volksarmee war halt der eine relativ,
Clara Armee so Nase die hatte halt auf ihre supportstrukturen unseren die wohl hat von dem,
so wird in die News unterstuetzt aber die Wahrheit Erwin relativ klare gut bin ich nicht.
Ja oder so Falklands Krieg so nen.
King of Oakland so genau so halt so vorgehen war halt so einer der letzten Aktion nur mal sagen kann so das war noch mal so richtiger key,
Nokia.de wie hin und Sohn,
und seitdem ist das halt alles in seiner Diffusion verschwunden und er deswegen wichtig weil.
Nur so lässt sich dieser Begriff Cyberwar korrekt interpretieren weil,
7 nicht darum geht das wäre so klare Länder haben die jetzt gegeneinander halt irgendwie antreten dann sind halt Interessen die,
so verschleiert werden unter so vielen,
ja Leon oder mitzufühlen Indirektion das war wie sehr schwer zu sagen wir es eigentlich gerade gegen wen arbeitet und noch die Zielsetzungen,
süffig indirekt aus Amazon angucken die russischen Einfluss Operation Nase so wohin USA zu Europa,
waren ja nicht unbedingt darauf gerichtet jetzt einen Kandidaten oder eine Candida,
durchzubringen oder zu bekämpfen sollen die waren primär darauf gerichtet den.
Der sie die Fähigkeit der Gesellschaft zum nationales Kurs zur Meinungsbildung zu zerrütten.
Deshalb so ein Ding wo diese sie gerade so Cyber Operationen mit jemand hackt einpacken wütend findet halt Daten und liegt diese Daten in der Form die halt zeitlich und contextual gut passt.
Deshalb ein weiteres Prusa MK3 weitere Puzzlestein Auseinandersetzung die aber sie viel größer ist und deswegen was uns auch wichtig weil das einzuordnen zu sagen ok,
Cyber Wars jetzt nicht Wülfing so das große Ding was jetzt irgendwie isoliert für Sie,
betrachtet steht sondern deshalb Teil einer,
Auseinandersetzung zwischen Staaten die zunehmend unübersichtlich wird die hat zunehmend regellos wird und die hat auch einen großen Anteil daran hat dass wir diese Welt halt als irgendwie völlig unübersichtlich und was passiert ja eigentlich empfinden.
Also um das auch mal klarzumachen Cyberwar muss man,
richtig richtig verstehe jetzt nicht so sehr verstehen als der Krieg mit zahlbar,
Rose alle umso Laserkanonen aufeinander stehen oder sich irgendwie elektronisch ihre Rechner wegschießen auch wenn das natürlich ein halpick davon ist,
sondern es ist mehr Krieg in Zeiten von zahlbar wo einfach,
psychologische Kriegsführung,
unsere Aspekte die früher auch immer irgendeine Rolle gehabt haben aber vielleicht mehr erstmal nur so,
Zettel die irgendwie über dieses Gebiet abgeworfen werden um die Leute irgendwas glauben zu machen
quasi hoch zehn und.
Es wird in zunehmendem Maße auch so I Frontlinie,
ja also damit fängt es an,
beginnt schon bevor es eigentlich irgendwie ein Krieg ist also man kann sogar fast sagen es ist so eine Art dauert Kriegszustand indem man sich schon fast befindet.
Genau das hat eines der wesentlichen Charakteristika auf der der aktuellen kriege ist dass sie nicht enden ausgezahlt kein danach,
und deshalb so einsam. Es gerade jetzt mit dem Irakkrieg und das in dem was danach kam auch so deutlich wurde das so klar war so sobald irgend ein großer Staat anfängt und einen kleinen,
anzugreifen entsteht da halt so eine Zone,
Amazon so eine Konfliktzone die halt nie wieder zur Ruhe kommt in den nächsten Dekaden,
wo halt einfach klar ist wendet jetzt,
geteilt mal so weiter und du wirst in der nächsten Operation resultierte dann wieder diese russische Strategie,
ihr seid doch das was sie was sie da im im Donbass betreiben ist halt diesen Konflikt einfach auf kleiner Flamme am köcheln halten,
und Inhalt wieder hochdrehen wenn es gerade brauchen soll deshalb so ein Ding was strategisch neu ist also wo hat oder bin falls sehr sehr sehr langer Zeit nicht angemeldet wurde.
Oder man könnte auch sagen Nahost ist überall.
Kann das sein der OST ist überall wenn was denn zu lassen also bist aber so ein so ein Ding wo halt die.
Das ist ja so ein Wesenszug von Designer dieses Nahostkonflikts dass der nicht nicht endet nicht gelöst werden will weil zu viele ein Interesse daran haben ihn nicht zu lösen weil er immer wieder für irgendeine Agenda taub.
Aber im Prinzip hast du da also,
erinnere mich daran im Prinzip an diese beiden Zitate ewig Clausewitz irgendwann um 1800,
Krieg ist die bloße Fortsetzung der Politik mit anderen Mitteln,
was sind wahrscheinlich foco irgendwann 1975 zudem Codes animiert hat Politik ist die Fortsetzung des Krieges mit anderen Mitteln mehr was ich dir sehr viel schönere Zitat finde und.
Daraus spricht doch eigentlich die Auseinandersetzung der,
Staatengebilde untereinander ist nie unbedingt friedlich sondern ist irgendwie von eigenen Interessen geleitet und es gibt eben in zunehmendem Maße ein,
Zustand der zwischen zwischen dem wir haben jetzt offiziell den Krieg erklärt und wir wir vernichten jetzt solange die
Bevölkerung die Bevölkerung des anderen bis 4 bis einer heult und dann setzt einer seine Interessen durch sondern zusammen naja ok diese diese offene Konfrontation ist irgendwie eine,
eine unschöne Sache das heißt aber nicht dass wir nicht so eine,
so ein Zwischenzustand haben können da wo wir versuchen unsere Interessen in den anderen Ländern umzusetzen.
Na ich glaube das diese wichtige Zitat von Clausewitz der Krieg ist also ein Akt der Gewalt um den Gegner zu Erfüllung unseres Willens zu zwingen.
Genau davon willst du ab davon wird der eigentlich weg.
Bist eigentlich genau das was du was da passiert das nämlich die die Frage welche Art von Gewalt verwendest du,
sich heute erweitert hat auf dem digitalen Raum und das werden was wir sehen,
der Willen von Staaten hat sich in der Art und Weise miteinander auseinanderzusetzen wo sie die Eskalationsstufe möglichst granular kontrollieren können,
also halt also der so von diplomatischen incidence über Leute in anderer Leute Botschaften umbringen undsoweiterundsofort dass da also diese dieses
dieses Spektrum der Eskalation sich ausweitet und eben bisschen dazu geht dass man andere Leute Nennstrom ausgenutzt,
wie hat Smash gehört auf jeden Ukraine und.
Und aber trotzdem ist eigentlich immer noch kein kriegerischer Akt ist und dass er sozusagen dieses diese Auseinandersetzung also kriegerischer Akt im Sinne von Manfred Mann Kanonen aufeinander,
aber diese diese Auseinandersetzungen aber trotzdem schon für die Bevölkerung ZDF nicht dramatisch sein können,
wie hat kleinere kriegerische Handlungen Ersatz,
Brustkrebsbehandlung hat immer größere Verjährung als ein venensalbe Angriff aber,
bin halt schon paar Wochen der Strom und woraus ist dantri,
ja und das heute schon so eine oder wenn halt die die logistiknetzwerke,
kaputt gemacht werden und du dann halt zurückfallen musst auf,
ja Notversorgung das mit Jahr einschicken musst und dann Brot hinzubringen dann bist du halt schon in deiner staatlichen Souveränität stark eingeschränkt.
Oder ein Land dazu zu bringen irgendwie aus Eisen Handelsverträgen auszutreten und danach irgendwie komplette Hose runter da zu stehen ich meine meiner Meinung nach ist auch brexit Alzheimer überhaupt.
Ergänzt um und dass das ist das was ich gerade meinte ist von du will,
ohne dass deine dein Ziel Start das notwendigerweise dir zu schreiben kann.
Das hast zumindest bei also zumindest was irgendwie rein digital Operation angeht also wo du halt andere Leute Rechner aufmachst oder in die Stromnetze runter fährst,
ihr seid so dass diese Zuschreibung wer ist jetzt steht jetzt gerade dahinter Wer ist denn der Urheber davon geht,
das hat noch sehr viel schwieriger als wenn du da an welche Truppenteile ohne Uniformen hast oder mit irgendwelchen fantasieuniform,
danke hast du Zweifel immer noch irgendwelche Anhaltspunkte aber wenn du halten digital angefasst,
fällt dir auch sehr leicht so zu tun als wärst jemand anders als eine falsche Fährte zu legen und du kannst auch sehr viel einfacher,
diese gesamte Attributionen ja vermeiden oder hintergehen und sind nur sehr seltene Fälle die dann durch die Presse gehen wo so ein Attributionen wirklich gelingt also mal sagen kann ok,
kann man jetzt ausnahmsweise mal doch glauben Wald hat ihm nicht nur die Kaffeesatzleserei aus diesem l wer wurde zu Moskau Bürozeiten compiled ist sondern halt irgendwie einen.
Tatsächliches Jahr in die die Rechner des der Russen eingedrungen gewesen,
Kinder beim Arbeiten zuguckt haben so oder,
andere Methoden zum also meiner Meinung nach sind viele von diesen Attributionen die jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit mit,
viele sind ja nur eine kleine Antwort wo die Amerikaner gesagt haben sie haben,
sehr hohe Konfidenz in dieser tivation,
ich denke die meisten von denen beruhen darauf dass sie menschliche Quellen sind im Schatten.
Ja weil die nur dandini sich eigentlich so aus dem Fenster so aber der Großteil von dem Moment sagtet weitere die rosmala wann jetzt die Chinesen sind halt so Attributionen die hört mir so auf,
naja so Kaffeesatzleserei beruhen also entweder wir haben die Mail wär schon mal gesehen und damals haben wir sie den Russen zugeschrieben deswegen muss jetzt wohl auch dieses Mal die Russen gewesen sein,
was totaler Quatsch iswipe,
noch eine kriminelle Male Version ist völlig üblich dass mehr wie recycelt wird das nimmst du mir von euch jemand anders,
aus dem bisschen um und verwendest du als deine eigene muss sie nur command control austauschen,
oder man macht halt so eine wem hat's genutzt so also sind die Ziele ja angerufen worden würde es eher den Russen nutzen oder eher den Chinesen so oder wie auch immer
und wir wissen halt er aus dem sowas wie den den liegt von Wolf seven was also DC Rituals waren
das ist da große Sammlung gib,
die angelegt werden von mehr wer anderer starten,
Buderus zum Nutzen so zu tun als wäre man jemand anders Nase wurde zum ersten Mal richtig belegt,
kostet also natürlich angewendet Taktik ist und da besteht diese ganze Attributionstheorie,
in so ein Ding gesagt bis auf ein paar wenige Ausnahmefälle
hat in diesem Bereich des Ungewissen wo man halt einfach nur sagen kann so in den alarm,
Filmbusiness ich warte Portion eigentlich nicht möglich sondern nur sondern über könnte sein.
Also das ist doch ein relevanter Teil dieser
dieser Auseinandersetzung oder so diese diese Unsicherheit dass du selbst neu Wendy
jedes Mal wenn da irgendwas groß durch gefeiert wurde dann steht einer auf und sagt das waren aber die dann werden regelmäßig eigentlich Leute die sich damit auskennen Gefahr,
nicht selten du oder ich und müssen dann eigentlich streng genommen sagen naja also das was uns davor gelegt wird reicht halt nicht aus um
dem Glauben zu schenken was gezwungenermaßen natürlich auch der Fall ist also ein Staat wäre ja auch relativ.
Schlecht beraten ernsthaft zu veröffentlichen,
Basis welcher.
Kater von oder Erkenntnisse eine attribution vorgenommen hat weil das zur Folge hätte dass der das diese,
Zeichen in Zukunft von anderen kopiert werden,
bzw von denen die sie verraten haben falls es jetzt stimmte nicht mehr gezeigt werden da das heißt es dieses gesamte Ding ist gezwungenermaßen in so einem.
In so eine Attributionsfehler abgedampft.
Also wie nennt hat in dem Buch so ein bisschen das Spiegellabyrinth,
das sollte der seine Anspielung auf the violence of Mirrors ist und die,
das Problem ist halt am Ende des diese Abwesenheit von sicher attributiver Kite.
Frank halt auch die strategischen Möglichkeiten starke einen also gerade im amerikanischen Bereich ist es so dass viele,
von den gerade mit Hirschen Strategen gerne eigene sowas wieder Abschreckung hätten,
aber die würden gerne erinnern an apricum Strategie bauen die heute,
bodoky wenn wir nur genug aufrüsten dann wird dagegen dahin recht stark abgeschreckt dass wir an keine Angriffe flüchten müssen.
Und sie wohnen ja auch in den letzten sind wir 80 90 Jahren war das die.
Ja deswegen hat so schwer davon wegzukommen und jetzt anzuerkennen dass man
da nicht rauskommt damit aber sie versuchen sollte immer noch also der Großteil der der massiven Aufrüstung dir zu mir Server command da stattfindet,
dasdie der Versuch,
zusammen wie wir sind aber den dickeren und längeren deswegen greifen es mal lieber nicht an
der lauf doch natürlich weiter also auch schon aus Gründen Rheine komischen Gründen weil die ganzen contr,
und die ganzen Rüstungsfirmen hat dass ich gut dran verdienen und Sagen hat so wir müssen aber mehr und Sonne.
Es gibt doch auch Länder wo das tatsächlich gerade halbwegs funktioniert oder also,
mit Israel will sich eigentlich in dem Bereich keine anlegen.
Sag mal den Israelis außer die haben gerade echt viel Spaß mit den Iranern.
Also die dass es funktioniert doch genau da nicht,
also gerade also gerade Iran ist ein ich das beste Beispiel dafür dass es heute überhaupt nicht funktioniert mit dieser Abschreckung weil die natürlich können die Israelis da halt wahrscheinlich Hall piratennamen liegen wenn sich im weh tut man den Kopf setzen.
Machen sie aber nicht ne.
Machen wir halt nicht weil andersrum sie genau wissen dass sie heute Micha Weise die Antwort nicht vertragen,
und das hat genau der Punkt das also dieses diese diese Frage.
Können wir dann die Antwort verdauen wenn wir zu die offensiv Operation machen,
auch wenn diese zusammen falsch sind ne ist halt der einzige limitierende Faktor momentan aber es hat keine echte Abschreckung im Sinne von,
niemand macht nichts dann alle Tasten sich so ein bisschen so ran und versuchen Rost.
So und deshalb so also auf allen Seiten also auf die Amis sind die Russen und so gegeneinander und die,
und dann gibt's halt so komplexe Spiele wo wenn man halt mal die paranoide Interpretation nehmen würde könnte man sagen so na ja,
nachdem die Army ist echt sauer waren und Halt und wie gesagt haben hierzu müssen noch mal gegen die Russen zurückschlagen.
Nur noch unter Obama ne wobei mal offen gedroht hatte das war kurz vor kurz vor der Wahl oder.
Genau und dann gabs plötzlich den Shadow Brokers liegt er hat große Teile wie ist eines Inventars offengelegt hat,
so und das hat so die paranoider Interpretation ist halt zu sein so naja das waren halt die Russen weil sie damit halt den kommenden Gegenschlag Hall,
Gehalt dann wieder Amerikaner halt anziehe gestoppt haben weil klar war
die stehen gerade so ein bisschen nackig da vorher Waffenschrank sein hat das halt so ein
wird aber deshalb so die die Dimension von von strategischen Abwägung die da halt gerade gespielt wird,
die hat doch nicht mehr so viel mit,
Nack,
was sieht der zu unmittelbar wird schnell entschieden ist schon beim nächsten Mal seine Strategien nicht mehr benutzbar weiter jetzt bekannt ist dieses protempo diese hohe ja Geschwindigkeit von.
Der Änderung von strategischen Grundsätzen.
Führte dazu dass diese ganze fällt aus so unübersichtlich wird dasselbe wie Sonne
Oman Air nur so grobe wage Einschätzung liefern kann halt sowie halt so die ganzen Länder wo lauft,
Rätsel und wie sie hat wohl reagieren werden aber eigentlich nicht sagen kann ok die Strategie ist total super und die wird jetzt auf jeden Fall funktionieren.
Ich fand den des den Shadow Brokers liegt den haben wir hier natürlich auch immer wieder angesprochen das,
ist irgendwie so ein Ding was mich so total noch fasziniert ne einerseits also mit welcher,
mit welcher Bösartigkeit also wirklich diabolisch das Ding irgendwie durchgeführt wurde ja so erstmal sozusagen übrigens schaut mal wir haben ja so ein paar Namen das könnten wir alles veröffentlichen also die Exploit Namen hatten die Shadow Brokers ja sehr früh veröffentlicht,
sie hatten aber nicht gesagt was halt die zugehörigen war nur abilities sind,
was letztendlich genau wie du gerade sagtest die,
die Rinde dieser Exploits Nutzen von der ganz fürchterliche Situation gestellt ha,
dass sie nämlich davon ausgehen mussten scheiße scheiße scheiße,
die sind jetzt in anderer Hand das heißt wer auch immer die in seiner Hand hat kann auch unsere Angriffe attribuieren das waren ja alles Zero des zu dem Zeitpunkt noch,
gleichzeitig dann dieses genüssliche scheibchenweise veröffentlichen.
Was am Ende noch in dem die saß in den beiden disaster wannacry und Notepad ja entscheidende Rollen gespielt hat.
Als Erklärung damals die wann hat,
zwei Würmer die glaube ich zur Mitte,
wenn ich nur was die anzahl Infektionen angeht Hannovers irgendwie,
Wirtschaft Iran und der zugrunde line Export war dieser Addon im Blu-ray,
Modern Talking alle Windows Computer funktioniert nun auf dem die NSA seit mindestens fünf Jahren ist Essen hat.
Und da natürlich auch was ich dann noch,
besonders eleganten fand,
Erinnern das war damals im Februar
Zug Microsoft sein Update zurück oder hat er hat das Update nicht wie erwartet herausgegeben im März kam dann anderes Update wohl Microsoft affensitz zitieren ein bisschen wichtig so gespielt.
Mach mal schnell ist.
Hübner,
Sandi Shadow Brokers eben dass das nicht nur das Wissen über die Schwachstelle für eternalblue,
in der Dateifreigabe SMB von Windows veröffentlichten sondern auch direkt dazu dass das Exploit also so hier probiert mir ausgeht fertig also das war dein Herz exploit.in the konnte man halt runterladen,
und da hatten sie einen Monat Zeit gegeben allen für das Update was sehr freundlich ist von den Shadow Broker.
Nötiges hatte einfach damit zu tun dass Ihre eine Systeme patchen müssen und Dativ realistisch einschätzen davon ein wie lange es dauert.
Aber also die waren zu wissen ich meine Handy die sind also,
es wird irgendwie in der offiziellen Geschichtsschreibung wird immer wieder davon ausgegangen dass die NSA Microsoft gewarnt hätte,
und ich gehe eigentlich fest davon aus dass die Shadow Brokers Microsoft gewann,
haben ja Kontrolle darüber wann Sie Ihr Exploit willison und dass sie einen Monat gewartet haben und zwar auf den Tag genau
zur wo sie jederzeit hätten sagen können Buch jetzt habe ich das hier auf Github hochgeladen delete delete delete wie Krieg,
das war fand ich ja doch relativ,
fair von den trotzdem am Ende dieses Release steht ein Monat später übrigens auch wieder ne hat er noch mal einen Monat gedauert bis einer welcher Akteur auch immer gesagt hat ich verbinde das mal mit einer Schadsoftware und guck mal was.
Habe ich den exponentialrechnung richtig aufgepasst habe ja habe ich die Welt liegt in Schutt und Asche so und wenn die das gemacht hätten zu einem Zeitpunkt wo,
wo noch nicht wo wo jetzt noch nicht das Bett der Petros gewesen wäre dann hätte der Cyberwar in rinjes.
An ihren Höhepunkt gefunden und dass ich darin zeigt ist eben,
in dieser Veröffentlichung jetzt so Dietmann geht ja davon aus,
ist die Shadow Brokers unter Umständen ein russisches einen russischen unter Interessen unterliegendes,
Teamwork placed sind ja noch nicht fertig soweit ich das sehe.
Aber länger nichts mehr getan.
Die machen gerade ein bisschen Urlaub die erholen sich von den ganzen anstrengenden releases.
Ist ja noch schön auf der Krim.
Während die.
Wannacry & Notepad jajaja in Richtung Nordkorea Attribut.
Renault bitte russisch.
Jpc russisch wannacry.
Nordkorea provoziert er also das nordmedia russisch war es halt,
natürlich nicht bewiesen so aber das halt so eine Sonne
erinnere dich klassische wie benutze ich Attributionen
sie haben heute wie die ukrainische Software-Qualität Elster,
hat Ukraine infiziert aber die Steuer Einreichung Software und dann daraus dann halt an wie ihre Verbreitung bezogen.
Das bringt uns auf einen interessanten. Ihr hattet ja gestern so eine Buchvorstellung der Sache,
Porno mit dabei war schon ganz unterhaltsamen Diskussion,
das Thema Softwarequalität bitte auch eine große Rolle bei eurer,
Malteser weil jetzt muss man das ja auch mal fragen okay also,
aber wo findet statt Tor wir haben also quasi so eine,
Timer Variante von Kriegsführung Dauerzustand der Zerrüttung psychologische Kriegsführung elektronische Kriegsführung alles Teil des Geschehens aber,
nicht ohne auch normalen Krieg der halt vielleicht mit einer Mitteln ausgetragen wird aber trotzdem immer,
Rasen Palma nach diesem Ziel hat nämlich das irgendjemand an den Willen aufzwingen möchte,
jetzt spielt die elektronische Infrastruktur natürlich eine besondere Rolle.
Und habe ihr hattet ein bisschen stuks nicht also ein bisschen als du den,
also die die Angriffe auf die iranische Atomstrahlung Anreicherung,
ein bisschen so als den Urknall diese Problematik ausgemacht habe ich das falsch verstanden im Moment.
Nee schon richtig aber zumindest war es unser Moment der Öffnung der Büchse der Pandora,
wo man eigentlich sagen kann ob da gings los was den modernen also die aktuelle Zeitrechnung diese Auseinandersetzung an geklappt hat wie ich vorher auch schon nur halt nicht in diesem Maßstab und,
das Stück sendet hat halt sehr vielen.
Starten klargemacht was da geht wenn man genügend Ressourcen drauf schmeißt.
Davor war das US Science-Fiction ne.
Nee voll passiert Esprit mir halt im Spionage Bereich Zoo und in der Art und Weise die jetzt nicht,
so offen war na so man hat halt sich gegenseitig natürlich die Hardware,
infiziert oder implants eingebaut und so weiter deshalb schon alles passiert aber,
sag mal so eine richtig große Cyber Sabotage der gibt halt diese persistente Geschichte dass die Serena mithalten Gaspipeline in Russland gesprengt hätte neben Sidari
die Pumpen manipulierter dass ich Software der Pumpen die Geschichte ist aber so im Wagen dass sie halt
generell als kann.
War das die von den gleichen Blumenberg Autorin die jetzt über Hardware implants geschrieben haben.
Also meine meine Vermutung jetzt auch Berlin hat er diese Hardware implant Geschichte aber auch damals bei dieser Partei Geschichte ist dass die halt so,
Quellen haben die Sachen gehört haben die schon passiert sind aber halt in einer gewissen Verzerrung oder durch das,
Echo von realna eigenes in die sie dann halt irgendwo in der,
leicht veränderten Version halt irgendwie weiter erzählen konnten und David University,
diese,
diese Frau dazwischen Sabotage vorher sicherlich gab es die vorher aber nicht mit einem so großen Aufwand zumindest so weiter wissen also kann ja mal sein dass du von Operation nichts mitbekommen haben das ist halt
er kann's, dass es dir wir sehn strucksdamm Schrunden so ein bisschen Alsen
so eine Zäsur weil danach eben auch andere Staaten im großen Umfang angefangen haben zusammen so Kay,
wird es eine tolle Sache mit wollen wir auch ne und angefangen haben ihre eigene Ausrüstung dazu treiben.
Und würde wie würde man in die zurückbringen Stücken Stück seid ist doch jetzt auch bald zehn Jahre her oder.
Was nicht muss man nach.
Würde ich jetzt oder Alkoven müsstest oder oder.
10 acht Jahre das heißt das ist schon vor zehn Jahren an.
Die Oppa die Operation damals war ja es ging darum der Iran Reich hatte,
Uran an und es war ein sehr sehr gezielter Angriff auf die Siemens zentrifix Zentrifugen.
Na die Steuerung der sieben.
Zu der Zeit wo die alternativ diskutiert dass Israel darüber fliegt und den die Anlagen kaputt brummt,
insofern diese Operation Israel und die USA an haben immer alle geschrien Iran hör auf hör auf hör auf auf auf wir wollen das iranische Atomprogramm stoppen durch diese sabbotage wurde das programm auf jeden Fall ein paar Jahre zurückgeworfen.
Und man könnte es sogar oder ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass das Team was das damals gemacht hat sich im Prinzip so ein bisschen als quasi ja besonders,
positiv und klug gewitzt und irgendwie auch,
als etwas Gutes sieht weil was dass ich keine,
keine nuklearphysiker wurden im Rahmen dieser Operation verletzt.
Na das stimmt nicht ganz also die zwei wiederum auch,
Bestandteile Größen Operation und im Rahmen dieser Operation,
haben die Israelis systematisch iranische nuclear Physiker umgebracht die haben im.
Habe ein anderes Team not my department.
Naja vielleicht nicht direkt das Tiger-Team aber nie aber sagt ein gutes Beispiel dafür dass es halt immer eingebildet ist in Größe Operation und das ist halt niemals nur das Eiweiß sondern man hat NIE versucht immer holistisch zu betrachten
also dieser Erfolg,
würde operationeller Erfolg ist sicherlich.
Für viele Nachfolge Sachen im Vorbild gewesen aber.
Die Panik wieder hinterher daraus resultierte dass man lange nicht wusste.
Was macht diese Möwe eigentlich,
man lange auch nicht wusste dass diese Mail wäre so dermaßen gezielt ist dass sie wirklich sich nur auf dieser,
spezifischen Anlage komplett auspacken kann das ist ja so gebaut gewesen dass die nur wenn alle Parameter richtig waren,
hat diese mehr was ich habe komplett ausgepackt,
drei lange nicht klar und erschüttert zu seiner großen Panik darüber dass dies dieses Tuxertal,
in diversen Austria Anlagen weiterverbreitet hat also hattet ihr auch in deutschen Kraftwerk gefunden also Klausuren Atomkraftwerken,
nur dass es halt da nichts getan hat gesagt hat sich dahin gruppierte geguckt manchen richtigstellen öp schneien.
Google Maps an.
Alsop überall so Bomben installiert sind die aber nicht scharf gestellt.
Glaub dir doch auch nicht funktionieren würden weil sie hat die falschen Controller angreifen würden also seid aber es hat super,
das hat so eine Wiese noch Matroschka gebaut.
Hast als packt sich immer ein Ding nach dem anderen aus aber auf der Basis von Umgebungsparameter was hat dazu führt dass es halt,
Bansin ihr sehnlicher die Anlage ist dass du mir Matroschka talrain ausgepackt aber bekommst Harley zum Ziegelwände halten,
genau diese Konfiguration hast du uns schon so gebaut das ist halt relativ,
ja also Archivgut engineered war aber.
Auch eine unglaubliche intelligence an man muss ja dazu auch erstmal wissen wie da die Bedingungen sind.
Und der Tag vorher vorher freue mehrwerk campaigns die heute genau dazu dienten,
genau dieses Zubehör zu erreichen war dieses Land und flame und noch ein paar andere die hat da,
in dieser Olympic Games Kampagne halt gelaufen sind und das Problem war halt also eine Begrenzung der interne,
Dyon enter Code mehrmals die wussten schon dass sie da relativ weit vorne am Rahmen des Machbaren operieren aber die.
Aber die haben halt den.
Also die die intelligence darüber haben die wahrscheinlich auch mit machine Thorsten zum Teilen gesammelt aber der Wiese also auf der strategischen Ebene war das halt so,
okay wenn man dann nur noch genug Geld drauf klebt und dann mal irgendwie 10 20 million e-hand nimmt,
dann kann man sowas erreichen denkbar 39 auf der anderen Seite,
budavar vielen Staaten auf ihre Verwundbarkeit klar sein und dieses,
deshalb hat er die Diskussion halt schon auch in die Richtung beeinflusst dass man also,
aber such mal andere Charge gemerkt,
das vielen dann klar wurde okay das mit der Rhein Offensivstrategie wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren ne wenn wir jetzt eine Mail wäre die.
Von den Amis gegen Iran getackerte wird in deutschen Kraftwerken finden.
Sagt schon bisschen was darüber aus wie schnell deshalb schiefgehen kann ne also wie,
schlimm halt die die Lage ist und das halt so und da gibt's halt o2 Folgerungen Orden raus zum einen,
Hamm viele Staaten danach angefangen hat massiv auf dem See Kapazitäten aufzubauen dafür war ich doch nur ein bisschen so die Initialzündung dann auch noch später halt bevor durch die Snowden Enthüllungen alcidan mitbekam hier somit Bilder kommen und sowas da gerade auch die Briten,
dazu veranstalten und wie gut die darin sind und zum anderen ist aber diese Frage was machen wir jetzt eigentlich der defensiv Seite,
im so ein bisschen in den Hintergrund.
Was auch immer warum wird Buch geschrieben haben wir Sachen sagen ok,
Gucci,
wir sind jetzt in Deutschland gerade im Punkte Diskussion welche Behörde baut jetzt welche offensiv Kapazitäten auf irgendwie hier von allein hätte gerne,
S1000RR Soldaten und frag mich wo Sie die herkriegen wäre.
Kristallkongress Besucher einsperren oder so.
Zwangsrekrutierung weil sie läuft in allen Ländern Hannah dass sie versuchen halt Anbieter Land,
gehen oder sich halt irgendwie Tools von denen den contractors einzukaufen die da in dem Bereich unterwegs sind und die,
Frau gesagt ob Deutschland dieses Spiel mitspielen sollte und das unserer Sicht halt eben nicht ist halt so ein bisschen so der unser Ansatz zu sein so man kann auch eine vollständig defensives selber Strategie bauen,
so klar sind wir Hacker wir machen noch gerne Dinge kaputt so das ist halt irgendwie natürlich anpustet macht halt mehr Spaß,
aber ist halt leider ständig die Franzosen an,
wichtig wäre halt dass ich dafür zu sorgen dass wir diesen riesigen Bestand an schlechter Software schlampigen Konfigurationen die her,
der Bodensatz sind soll es sein die Blumenerde auf der dieser Cyberwar kramen,
den hat mal offen ja dorthin sicheren Beton umzustellen.
Ich würde nur also noch kurz ergänzen der der Grund warum Stux nicht so unglaublich spitz,
seine Umgebung achten musste bis aktiv wurde war ja dass die letzte,
Danzas anderes sie leben in einem = Netzwerk also ärgert heißt nur das Ding ist nicht mit einem,
Internet und auch nicht hängt nicht ermittelten hängt auch nicht irgendwo an andere Maschinen die haben Internet hängen sondern,
hier hast du einen Haufen Computer die haben,
kein Internet,
und genau das war ja dann auch der Infektionsweg der genutzt wurde der der der spannende seo-day in der ganzen Aktion nämlich ein USB exploit.in Microsoft,
window Auswahl den klawa wenn du ein = Netzwerk hast muss ja trotzdem irgendwie Daten da rein oder wieder rauskriegen sei es nur die regelmäßigen Updates die irgendwie kommen was machst du du gehst mit USB-Stick hin und her,
das war letztendlich der Weg wieder irgendwann an einem schönen Tage
ein iranische Nuklearanlagen betreiben da Angestellter mit einem USB-Stick von einem Internet verbunden Rechner zu einem R gegerbten Rechner ging und dann,
der Rest ist dann eben irgendwann Geschichte gewesen und.
Insofern war Stuck sind natürlich auch eine lies auch die Interpretation zuzusagen eher egal wie sicher wir das machen und wenn wir sogar die Computer gar nicht mit dem Internet verbinden dann kommt da trotzdem noch jemand dran.
Was ist nur weit genug.
Gleichzeitig diese Herausforderung hast du natürlich bei dem,
größeren Teil der Infrastrukturen die du beabsichtigst anzugreifen hast du die gar nicht,
also du findest ergibt Netzwerke halt also ergibt,
kommt von Luftschlucken es gibt eine luftglocke zwischen,
dir und dem Internet die findest du in den in den hoch kritischen Infrastrukturen was weiß ich,
AKW ist da hast du findest du sowas ne aber,
in vielen in viele Bereiche kommst du auch rein ohne dass du diese,
diese besondere Herausforderung hast ja du hast nämlich meistens hast du Leute die sagen ja,
der Zugriff auf unsere Anlagen ist ja aber nur aus dem int
Beispiel pc-wahl ja das war genau,
genau so ein Fall wo sie sagt ja der hahaha das ist der fängt ja gar nicht am Internet
nur die kaputten Endpunkte von denen wir darauf zugreifen die hängt natürlich am Internet Hallo wollen Sie,
wollen Sie 100 Millionen Dollar gewinnen klicken Sie auf diesem Porno denkt er so irgendwie sind diese diese Art von von Sicherheit und damit,
das war.
Wieso bist du sowieso ein Museum was sagt immer so ja ne hier kann man gar nicht einbrechen weil da wo die Wertsachen liegen,
die haben ja gar keine Türen zu Straße,
ja
dahinter Räume sind die dann irgendwann eine Tür zu Straße haben so wird aber halt übersehen.
Das ist also genau da das Desing musste Stups seid so spezifisch sein wenn jetzt dein Angriffsziele mal ein bisschen niedriger legst sagen wir.
Sagen wir Deutschen Bundestag ja dann lädst du dir der letzte dir von guitar,
din Standard Trojaner Toolkit runter,
und wie ist das da rein du hast ja keine Lust deine besonderen Fähigkeiten hier zu verballern,
an einer Stelle wo du sie nicht brauchst das fand ich eigentlich auch das interessante Anstoßzeit das ist ok da muss.
Dr Wahlchancen,
und es war halt aber so ein in gewisser Weise Artikel,
nur weil der Großteil der angeführt die wir so sehen und die hatte auch stattfinden auch von statten neben hatte sich so standen erwehren,
und benutzen halt nur leichte Variationen davon weil man die Virenscanner sehen sowieso noch 5,
MR Wetter draußen Aussage Symantec größte Hersteller.
Das was bekannte.
Genau großer Hersteller von dem Zeug und bis dann halt mal so eine riesen richtige mehr wer auffällt,
dann eigentlich nur anhand des Command & control Traffics und,
da gibt's dann halt so leicht zu realisieren Innovationen wo du dann halt raus bist aus dieser Direktion also z.b. die wenn beim Bundestag sagt war ja so any beim beim Bundesverkehrsministerium Tag,
was ist sodass der Angriff erfolgt der über Neger,
Webseite über die dann halt diese Trojaner getropft wurden und der Command & control war über E-Mail.
Das hast du ja ganz normal E-Mails geschickt die haben nicht irgendwie zu berichten bekannten russischen Botnet Controller sowie Verbindung aufgebaut hat die haben einfach mehr als geschickt haben Gmail-Adresse.
Das war schon schön elegant und der und der Bundestags Hektar zwei Jahre davor der dir mir Mimi Katze benutzen
irgendwie so ein Standard Ding was du dir getroffen runterladen kannst übrigens
nur kurzer Exkurs ich habe Michaels habe ich hier im Blog bekomme vor einiger Zeit erzählt mich auch mal mit einem langjährigen cyberkrieger unterhalten,
der sagte na ja also sie haben auch immer,
puls verwendet die hatten im Prinzip gar keine großartigen eigene Installation
oder Eigenentwicklungen der Standard Tools verwendet immer schön gegoogelt ob es neue cvsg,
auf ihre Angriffsziele passten und so wer sagte eigentlich sein größtes Problem war oder sein größter Kopfschmerz war immer
das auf den Horst die sie sich irgendwie geschnappt hatten sich plötzlich auch irgendwelche Script Kiddies rum tummelten,
also was ist ein Begriff also auch andere Hacker die jetzt nicht,
politisch motiviert waren sondern die 18 legal hier machen an IRC Server hier mach mal falsch herum und so weiter.
Die sich aber aus denselben Quellen bedient haben also CVE sind.
Die die gleichen.
Die dokumentierten Sicherheits.
Sich auch halt irgendwelche Haus geschnappt haben die sie im Internet gefunden hatten die vielleicht wussten oder nicht wo,
und der hatte in der Infrastruktur eines.
Eine Zielfahnder was jetzt auch für staatliche Akteure interessant war,
wo die dann dort irgendwie so Yolo gesagt haben ja geil hier
lass mal dick Traffic machen und wir wird verteilt hier Warez oder Wir laden jetzt hier ist viel Platz da können wir porn draufladen oder so ja und es war eben für ihn immer der größte Ärger,
dass die nämlich so viel Lärm gemacht haben dass Admins darauf darüber gestolpert sind deswegen war seinem,
seine erste Anweisung immer die Schwachstelle über die wir reingekommen sind die DPD Päckchen wir weg,
und mit dem hatte ich zu tun da waren wir für eine größere Infrastruktur auch zuständig,
und er sagte als allererstes hier pass auf ich will das überall ein paar ungepatchte Büchsen rumstehen.
Und ich will einfach nur Checks haben ob die noch umgepatcht sind und wenn mir eine meiner ungepatchte wüchsen hier gepatcht wird ne dann fahren wir alle Tore runter,
das war seine dass er seine Maßregel oder seiner seine Maßgaben riesiges Projekt
rausgeholt hat gesagt überall so ein paar ungepatchte Dinger eingestellt die auch wirklich umgepatcht waren also das war jetzt,
weil sein Zeichen war der beste indicator of compromise ist das jemand die Dinger dass jemand die Schwachstellen Patch.
Also zumindest wenn du von den Profi explosiv.
Das war so seine also der Mann hatte halt.
Schönes Ding ich würde gerne jetzt schon.
Was hat gesagt so defensivstrategie hat mich jetzt auch noch mal daran,
dann ist ja auch mehrfach hier diskutiert und auch immer wieder diesen. Gemacht,
diese Ankündigung der Bundesregierung jetzt hier auch,
Morgen und einer Form sich aufzustellen,
ja um auch zurückschlagen zu können ja
Wasser immer so dieses Sinnbild von irgendwelchen FLAC schützen auftürmen hat ja dass das ja eigentlich bedeutet dass man auch aktiv an dem,
Cyberkrieg in dem Fall dem elektronischen rein elektronischen Cyberkrieg teilnehmen muss weil ein zurückschlagen ja nicht
bedeutet dass man dann irgendwann mal so die Computer hochfährt und mal gucken was man tun kann und dann ballert man einfach zurück soll dazu brauchen wir ja quasi einen permanenten Prozess,
anderer Leute Systeme,
eigentlich auch schon selber im Angriffskrieg drin ist also sozusagen diese dieses zurückschlagen ist eigentlich angreift,
und dementsprechend müssen hier auch verurteilt jetzt die Frage was ist denn die richtige,
Strategie wie könnte man sich hier aufstellt ist man dann sozusagen auch schon,
Teil der Friedensbewegung wenn man defensivstrategie sich auf die Fahnen schreibt.
Also also neutrales mehrere Komponenten die man braucht zum einen,
Quest man ganz einfach anfangen erstmal sowas wie nicht anders Abkommen schließen also einfach erstmal mit dem Starten die mit denen des diplomatischen möglich ist einfach nur mal Abkommen Sony wir selber das nicht.
Auch schon zwischen USA und China z.b.
Nur dass das Problem dabei war halt dass die Chinesen das Abkommen nicht mit den USA geschlossen hatten weil mit Obama,
ihre Interpretation Tiere Interpretation der Sachlage Wahrheit wir haben Abkommen Obama,
und nachdem dann halt drum eingeschworen war hatten sich da nicht mehr so richtig dran gehalten.
Du bist nicht unser Brot.
Wir wissen nicht ob du dich daran halten wirst also.
Was soll ich denn.
Bist du musst ziemlich genau das hätte ich nicht anders.
Gut also trotzdem hat er gezeigt dass es funktioniert also das halt so also da haben wir auch mit Leuten geredet auf der auf der amerikanischen Darkside und die meinten hatte ja tatsächlich funktioniert aber die Anden anzahl der Angriffe ist signifikant nach unten gegangen die halt irgendwie zu China attributive war,
und danach ist ja wieder hoch gegangen ist hat so ein so ein Ding und so eine Abkommen,
natürlich kann man einwenden ok man kann ja nicht verifizieren weil du kannst halt und wie keine Trojaner Zielen oder Reha Anzahl von fegen häkeln messen oder was auch immer total schwierig aber Sonderabkommen funktionieren ja anders und Abkommen sind ja nicht Gesetze,
na Abkommen sind ja Ausdruck des Willens von starten.
Zu sagen okay wir wollen gerne dass die Eskalation runtergeht oder das ist halt und Event eskaliert sehr viel langsamer geht das wäre so uns reinkommen dass wir uns zumindest ein bisschen Vertrauen,
was bestimmte Dinge nicht tun,
und als eines der ersten ab komm,
möglich sein wirst du tun ist zwischen den Nuklearmächte nen,
eine Vereinbarung zusammen wir schreiben uns nicht unsere nuclear Command & control system also die mit den ihr thomassen kontrolliert werden also es wäre schon mal ein guter erster Schritt I also so wo man hat sein könnte. Er macht mal bitte ne mach mal bitte möglichst schnell.
Hast du das Altersheim am ein Verb wird irgendwie.
So
Danton der nächste Schritt wir halt kritischer Infrastruktur an dass man sagt okay,
Kurt Spionage wird sowieso einfach passieren aber keine Angriffe kritische Infrastrukturen und ironischerweise haben die Russen so um 2000 rum,
Jammer,
die wollen das was damals Information warfare hieß heute als Cyberwar heißt.
Per Konvention echten.
2000 rum es war noch was vor Putin dass ich seit heute also so.
Dran guter Vorschlag na seid und gehaltene,
Vorschlägen was man alles nicht machen soll und dazu gehörte unter anderem hat Einfluss Operation dazu gehörte,
Einflussnahme auf die staatliche Souveränität des anderen über politische UPS dazu gehörte halt irgendwie Anrufe kritische Infrastruktur und so weiter sofort also,
die gesamte Liste von allem was sie gerade tun.
Also das hat gesagt ihr Playbook steht in dieser diesem Vorschlag für eine ohne Konvention.
Und passiert es dass das die Amis so tauchen,
sind wir gerade besser drin es wurde uns ja auch nur unnötig einschränken unsere Handelsraum wollen wann ich und habe es abgeschossen.
Also putin ist seit Mai 2000 Resi und seit,
99 Varga.
Okay also muss irgendwo so kurz kurz in dieser also in dieser Zeit ungefähr gewesen sein dass sie das versucht haben und ne und die Amis haben seit abgeschossen und lustige bei den Russen ist ja immer die nehme soweit durch das ernst nur muss dir denn nur zuhören,
wenn die heute sagen soll.
PayPal wir haben es euch gesagt hast jetzt nicht so dass ihr überrascht tun könntet oder ihr seid so außer sobald das neue Abkommen und so muss man immer bedenken,
Dip zu internationales Völkerrecht irgendwie FinePrint lesen da sind die Russen die Weltmeister drinne können ja meiner besten mit dir am besten selber total überrascht von diesen Verträgen so drin steht ebenfalls.
Datum sind Vorstoß man könnte diese sogar diese Rosenrot UN-Konvention Vorschlag von 2000 könnte einfach nehmen kurz ein paar Formulierungen updaten die mittlerweile bisschen antiquiert sind und den einfach wieder einbringen nur könnte mal einfach machen und währenden gute Wörter sind eine gute Regelung.
Rudolf die Welt besser machen.
Wenn man jetzt gerade mal eine USA Regierung hätte die jeder sowas les.
Also wenn wir jetzt also wenn jetzt irgendeine Regierung dem Sicherheitsrat Sitz ich was heißt Deutschland Grad und sichert reicht glaube ich.
Wie kommen jetzt darf ich wieder rein.
Was ist Ivan epic choeling wenn die deutschen einfach mal diese russische Konfektion nehmen die einen bringen würden,
in der Union sagen würden so übrigens wir haben ja dann für dieses diesen russischen Vorschlag aus dem Jahre 2000 irgendwie in unseren Archiv and gefunden und wir würden den gerne noch mal einbringen weil wir fanden nämlich eigentlich ganz gut.
So und dann mal gucken wie die Russen reagieren aber ich weiß nicht genau unser außen ist haben gerade so viel Humor hat.
Wann kommt kommt nächstes Jahr wieder in den Sicherheit.
Birnen sehr schöne Aktion so für Deutschland im Sicherheitsrat einfach mal genau dieses Ding wieder auszupacken.
Also wir haben das ist natürlich richtig die also internationale,
Verständigung oder Verträge oder Einigung finden in den Bereichen stadtwurst eigentlich dann auch nur noch das Vertrauen gibt ja so wo man sagen kann ok ihr habt Nuklearwaffen.
Wir auch wir können uns jetzt hier in die Augen schauen und ein bestimmtes Abkommen darüber treffen wir die einsetzen oder nicht und das wird solange dieses Vertrauen hält,
den Frieden voranbringen ja.
Oder über die Vernichtung solcher Waffen und sonstiges dann kann man sich sagen ok vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist besser wir lassen eure Kontrolleure rein das wäre alles möglich diese Vertrauens stiftenden,
Maßnahmen hast du aber in so einem Cyber Abkommen quasi nicht.
Der richtige Vergleich ist eigentlich eher dass das ohne Chemiewaffen Abkommen,
aber jedes Land was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise Halt und hin ich die Mission Austria Testanlage Chemiewaffen zu bauen,
trivia das Ding kann jeder seine Küche machen oder so,
Kannst verheerender Chemiewaffen bauen mit FE niedrigsten Technologie Niveau.
Warum passiert nicht weil es so sich geächtet ist also weil es einen internationale Vereinbarung dazu gibt wo wenn du dagegen verstößt.
Dann bist du auf jeden.
Hast du so richtig im Unrecht zu sehen wer gerade in dieser Syrien Geschichten hast dazu,
zsh dir eigentlich richtige Vergleich Atomwaffen ist der falsche vergleiche,
ich mir auch noch kommen ist die richtige Vergleich wenn man sagt ok ist der Technologie die hat jeder die kann jeder die es hat keinerlei Hörde,
so alt wird keine Antwort Behörde er trotzdem macht gerade und warum macht keiner weil du damit dann sofort in deep shit bist international,
das glaube ich dir richtige das Richtige Paradigma an was man halt auch sehr für Cyberport Zion finden sollte wo man sagt okay,
Es gibt Dinge die tut man einfach nicht und wenn du sie tust dann setze Dich halt ins Unrecht setzt sich der Gefahr von Sanktion aus und so weiter und sofort nutzen,
deutlich Hinweise auf darauf dass auch wenn starten,
jetzt nicht unbedingt die vertrauenswürdigsten sind weil ihre Interessen hi,
stark von ihrer Situation divergieren und sie halt größer werden wollen was auch immer,
die Tipps da solche Abkommen wenn sie dann einmal ratifiziert sind ein relativ hohen Bremse fikt haben weiß
dagegen zu verstoßen Gänge Abkommen was das Land ratifiziert erfordert eine Entscheidung auf höchster politischer Ebene,
was macht nicht mal irgendsoein sobald Annas halber Leutnant beschließt dann nicht mal ebend.
Kann nicht tun dazu muss er seinen Chef fragen und der muss sein Chef verhindere sein Chef rein oder ganz oben angekommen,
das tut dann steht da an der Wand ohne,
kommt von oben an das hast du Richard halt einfach zusammen Drums Effekte führt dazu dass Eskalation langsamer laufen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sinkt das sowas passiert ist kein Gesetz nichts kann Naturgesetze also nichts wo du dich darauf verlassen kannst 100% aber es wird sicher unwahrscheinlicher.
Gesetzlich die also die Sache wäre okay man könnte es in einem ersten Schritt quasi einschränken auf.
Kritische Infrastrukturen das gesagt erste Ebene okay wir greifen unsere nuclear Infrastruktur nicht gegenseitig ein B,
vielleicht Wasser,
und Strom noch dazu reden irgendwie darüber machen Liste.
Auf Afghanen technischer Ebene ist natürlich.
Die der der der Unterschied zwischen Spionage und Sabotage ist ein relativ kleiner,
ich kann unter Umständen lange Zeit ein System infiltrieren und dort Spionage betreiben gleichzeitig von,
mein also von der von der Art der Übernahme die ich für diesen System erlangt habe auch in der Lage sein es abzuschalten also stellen wir uns vor ich würde einen
Telefon Telekommunikationsanbieter infiltrieren und nutze meine dort erlangten Fähigkeiten,
ein Jahrzehnt lang,
für Spionage sowie es jetzt die USA mit mit Europa gemacht haben,
käme es nun zum Konflikt würde man im Zweifelsfall die gleiche Infektion die gleichen das gleiche Team nutzen um zu sagen mach mal hier statt SCP mach's jetzt mal RM - RS,
und dann hättest Du quasi mit der mit der gleichen Art von.
Infektion von einer Spionage Tätigkeit.
In einer Sabotage Tätigkeit gewechselt.
Das hat dieses Problem.
Also in den Innen chargon heißt es Positionen einnehmen,
nasse wenne heute dich in System hinein begibst um hat und wie es mal da zu sein Unterhalt er geht an den Hausmeister melwitz hinterlegen die Wahrheit über den Zugang gewährleisten wo du halt dann einfach die Periode reintun kannst ihr hört und Information extrahierte den ganzen Kram runterfährt das halt so,
und deshalb nun,
großes Problem dass diese Trennung zwischen Spionage und Sabotage halten nicht ohne weiteres möglich ist und deswegen ist halt der letzten Endes auch nur eine wirkungs basierte Betrachtung möglich,
also kannst wenn dich wenn dir jemand Halt und wie die Kiste aufmacht und sich da einnisten.
Hängt sehr davon ab was du glaubst wer es ist und mit welchem Ziel wie du reagierst.
Da hättest Du also so eine Situation wie die Russen haben unsere Nuklearanlagen gesäubert und dann sagen San Jose Pablo geguckt.
Wir wollten gucken.
Ich habe nichts angefasst.
Bisschen Brennstäbe Horrortrip.
Der rote Club okay aber wir wissen.
Nee aber tatsächlich so essen ist ein erhebliches Problem und die.
Also alle Leute die halt in dem Bereich tätig sind sagen halt auch dass man wird nicht umhin kommen den,
überhaupt es einen Ring in Systeme schon Hörzu echten sozusagen so okay wenn du innensystem eindringst dann wirst du.
Aufhört zu halt unter die jeweilige Konventionen und das war's auf bestimmte Systeme sind per definitionem per Funktion die sie erfüllen Aufnahme.
Sowas lässt sich zurzeit nicht auseinanderhalten.
Da wäre natürlich jetzt gerade Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur eben dass das beste Beispiel als.
Auch immer so nur weil noch ein krasseres Bausperre nimmst du meine petrochemische Anlage,
wo du legitime Spionage legitimen Anführungszeichen Spionage,
also mit welchen Temperaturen und Drücken der gefragt wird und das ist die dazu sagen dir gekriegt wird also die,
zulassen Anna gebaut wird daraus kannst du halt richtig viel Geld ziehen würde dann weiß was die da gerade produzieren und kannst dann daraus wiederum die Schlussfolgerung ziehen halt irgendwas auf dem Weg macht demnächst passieren,
oder ob sie halt Optimierung gefunden haben um,
bestimmte Prozesse halt angeschnallt effizienter zum anderen Tag Betriebsgeheimnisse die Spionage Ziele sind auf der anderen Seite ist,
in den Controller sind mir das Industrie Controller in denen genau diese Parameter drin stehen in seiner petrochemischen Anlage anzugucken,
und ich da einzunisten Sabotage Ziel weil wenn du nebenbei noch die safety Controller Export ist dann kannst du es dir einfach sprengen.
Oder zumindest offline nehmen weißt du sie dir dieser Übergang zwischen Spionage und Sabotage ist nur deine Intention das hat nichts,
stimmt der Systematik an sich zu tun na du hast halt immer auch ein spionagegesetz Energieanlagen.
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage no Spy Abkommen kriegen wir ja nicht hin die werden bei uns Herr Fallert.
Das heißt sie sollten den Pofalla jetzt in die in den UN-Sicherheitsrat schicken das würde glaube ich schiefgehen der würde nämlich sagen es gibt keinen Cyberkrieg.
Und deutsche Anlagen sind sicher nee aber.
Das jetzt bei der Bahn der Welt schon im Engel geholfen wenn er mal die trailing verhindern könnte.
Der für den Timer kriegt ja jetzt einfach als schon so ja ich bin letzte Mal Bahn gefahren.
Kundenmanagement jetzt macht's sFr.
Kunden Messe ceiberweiber Kundenmanagement.
Sieg wie würde dieses also das wäre der Weg nach vorne jetzt sagen ok,
Position zu beziehen zu verbieten wäre im Zweifelsfall nah,
leider das was die mächtigen Nationen gerade schon sehr gut betreiben und wurde die wo wahrscheinlich sowohl die USA als auch Russland heute sagen würden.
Gut also meines minimal der minimal Schreibfehler hat Zusagen sorgi.
Dafür zu sorgen dass kritische Infrastrukturen kaputt gehen und,
dafür zu sorgen dass irgendwie diese Souveränität eines Staates und seine Handlungsfähigkeit durch selber Operation beeinträchtigt wird wird halt,
ja untersagt nur limitiert oder sie hatte mit Absätzen Minimalziel so und
meines Erachtens wird der Weg dahin auch nicht gleich direkt über am4 Deutschland machen vorschlagen oder sie hat fortführen oder kannst du probieren seit ich finde es und wie
episch wenn du gehst Außenministerium hat diese Sauce Hypo Puzzle nimmt und einfach wieder auf dem Tisch liegt gesagt wie findest wir erstmal zeitgemäß so.
Wäre auch mal gute Position gegenüber Russland zu ja wieso das wollte dir doch.
Beliebte auf das wolltet ihr doch nicht so.
Denke dass der Weg dahin erstmal prima über bilaterale Abkommen funktionieren oder sodass Länder oder Ländergruppen untereinander hat Vonderort,
nicht angefangen, Abkommen schließen und haben kg.
Wir tun es heute nicht gegeneinander die Situation auch schon dadurch verbessert war es halt dein für alle anderen Länder den Pool der möglichen anderen Attribute und Kandidatin reduziert das heißt also wenn man hat,
was hat angenehmer machen und wieso der so die OECD Länder beschließen okay wir machen das halt nicht untereinander,
dann hast du schon mal um die 40 Länder die raus.
Aber dann würde ich doch als also würde ich doch als Rohling spezialisierte Nation wie z.b. Russland,
jedes Mal wenn andere Abkommen schließen sofort,
alles daran setzen den Eindruck also da die Tracht und Misstrauen zu sehen.
Türkisch wir sind jetzt halt in der Situation die nicht einfach ist aber es heißt ja nicht das was ich trotzdem probieren,
zweiter Teil der defensivstrategie ist,
auf jeden sollen das einfach die technische Situation besser wird bis 9:30 Uhr,
Ding aber bestimmt auch schon paar mal drüber diskutiert einfach dazu sagen dass die so viel besser wird dazu wird smartmig in Issum brauchen dafür Kennzeichnungspflichten brauchen wie z.b. halt,
das auf eben die Tage red draufsteht wie lange Sicherheitsupdate bekommt in welcher Frequenz Haftungsregelungen für Betrieb und Errichtung und von ja Digitalsystem,
ist ein super komplexes Thema dann kann man euch wahrscheinlich mehrere Sendung drüber machen aber wir denken dass es ohne nicht gehen wird und,
ganz wichtig weiter durch Bildung also wir haben halt dieses Problem dass wir immer noch zu wenig Leute haben die wissen wie das geht,
und dir auch deswegen so teuer sind dass ich die meisten Unternehmen halt niemand leisten der Halt und ich von sicherheit wirklich Ahnung hat,
was hat dazu führt dass wir immer noch jede Menge schlechte Software produzieren,
völlig unnötigerweise sind meine wir haben mittlerweile Programmiersprache wo es heute schwierig ist sich den Fuß zu schießen,
wir wissen wie man zur verwirre fiziert wir sind in der Lage zur Führung zu auditieren und sagen können ok die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass da noch was drin ist es hinreichend gering da sind ganz weggehen wird es nie aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach zu reduzieren erhöht die Kosten für Angreifer und diese.
Die ganze mündet dann halt daran dass man das aktivieren müssen einfach anfangen Software neu zu schreiben und es heißt halt dass wir einen,
Dart,
Amos of licenses also eine die auch für kommerzielle Produkte verwendbar ist,
um dafür zu sorgen dass dafür Modul neu geschrieben werden geortet werden up-to-date Gehör,
werden die dann von allen verwendet werden kann damit wir halten nicht mehr so was erleben wie diese Open SSL disaster,
das hattest völlig unnötig es würde besser gehen aber so erfordern dass da nicht drei Leute in ihrer Freizeit dran,
Sanders ist heute einfach einen Team g + continor ich dafür finanziert wird dafür zu sagen dass diese Software so gut ist wie es gerade technisch machbar ist,
so das ist halt nicht teuer sind Eurofighter pro Jahr so ist jetzt und wie keine,
gigantischen Summen so wenn ich jetzt gerade höre feat,
die Banken haben gerade 55 Milliarden Steuergelder und viel zu ihren Zucker Kunden abgepumpt mit diesem kamex Zeug,
dafür hätten wir das Problem lösen können also dafür wäre dieses Problem dann schlechter Software einfach weg gelöst vorbei müssen wir nicht mehr drüber reden.
Deshalb so die Dimensionen die man über die nächsten 10-15 Jahre da vielleicht reinstecken muss wahrscheinlich rechnen Zehntel davon lassen Software schreiben ist jetzt auch nicht so teuer,
das hat und wie soll so ein Ding wo ich auch nicht verstehe warum,
wie immer noch darüber diskutieren müssen so oder so warum wir irgendwie bescheuerte Waffensysteme noch und nöcher kaufen warum wir läuten sie Geld für envy ihre talking Aktivitäten geben als,
ja Land warum wir in wie,
in Autofirmen halt irgendwie die Krone nachwerfen dafür dass sie halt irgendwie und betrogen haben und.
Die wichtigen Probleme sind nicht annimmt angehört so.
Oder den Verfassungsschutz.
Also jetzt ist er würde gerne mal auf den Punkt eingehen okay Software mal in ordentlich schreiben so natürlich dass das Predigen wir,
seit langer Zeit jetzt stellt sich dadurch die Frage wie sehen ja,
also der der Lifecycle eine Software Projektes ist ja irgendwie thing TV klein und schmal an dann noch irgendwie schöne dann fahr seid halt die Komplexität immer weiter aus Komplexität ist im Prinzip der eine Prädiktor für Schwachstellen
ja ihr komplexer du den Mist baust desto weniger wird das irgendwie noch mal jemand unter unter einen Hut bekommen,
und es gibt eben leider eine ganze Menge an sprechen die Menschen in Software.
Haben das heißt wenn wir uns zum Ziel setzen okay wir wollen jetzt.
Zeig mal eine solide Basis schaffen und die großen wichtigen Probleme der der Herausforderung ihren ID Sicherheit lösen heißt das ja aber auch das,
wenn das wirklich mal halten soll wir im Prinzip an zwei Kernproblem was machen müssen die heute,
eigentlich uns die ganze Zeit Kopfschmerzen machen einmal die hohe Komplexität zweitens die fehlenden die fehlende Agilität,
ja zu sagen okay wir haben jetzt hier etwas gebaut,
das ist jetzt ne was dass ich ein Back End von der Bank oder ein Telekommunikationsunternehmen oder oder was auch immer und das ist einer und diese ganzen kritischen Infrastrukturen unterliegen ja dem hohen Anspruch an ihre Stabilität.
Was ich eigentlich immer wieder,
hast du am Ende Trägheit und Komplexität man könnte sogar sagen irgendwie diese mangelnde Agilität und erhöhte Komplexität ist im Prinzip das Ergebnis von fehlgeleiteter Stabilität.
Messer nicht zwangsläufig so nass ist hat ne also die Frage dessen wie deine Augen die Sozialstruktur aussieht,
und wie die daraus resultieren ist das für euch Tektur aussieht und wir haben ja durchaus Ansätze aus wie z.b. halt etwas Hannes macht da mit Mirage Warez,
wo man halt einen.
Einen Ansatz willst du sagen wann installiert auf dem System wirklich nur die Zeilen zur für die man da wirklich braucht alle anderen sind einfach nicht da nimmt Colonel sind nur genau die Dinge drin die notwendig sind für die Funktion in dieser Form,
und alles andere ist halt einfach nicht da du hast halt einfach diesen ganzen Text Service nicht in Siegen zur Usability füreinander.
Radikaler Komplexität.
Genau,
das denke ich mal einen Ansatz auf den wir aus den sehen wir auch Sommerschuhe bei Google und bei den anderen großen die halt diese intern Entwicklung in diese Richtung treiben dass sie sagen,
wir haben Zero Trust network so also intern kann Server dem anderen traut wo es halt irgendwie darum geht dass man,
Versuch die an die Menge Zahlencode die auf einem System laufen möglichst klein zu halten,
daraus folgt dann halt eben doch die Möglichkeit so eine,
Formularen Ansatz zu fahren also unser Vater dazu sagen wir brauchen eine staatlich am besten europäische Agentur.
Die paar harte Limit hat die halt sagt,
wenn du neues Software schreiben willst dann ist dein.
Deine Größenordnung der du arbeiten kannst erstmal eine Millionen und ein Jahr also sieh mal zu was du mit einer Millionen oder einer halben Millionen einem Jahr hinbekommst,
und wenn du dann Was hast was heute irgendwie gut aussieht dann gibt's halt Anschlussförderung aber eben nicht,
50000000 zu Frauenhofer werfen damit sie halt irgendwie die eierlegende Wollmilchsau
das irgendwie,
mit dem Refrain wechseln wie integrieren kann sondern halt irgendwie ne,
kleine überschaubare codebase aus den man dann durch modulares zusammenbauen,
hat die Funktionalität realisieren kann die man braucht bloß dann halt ein bisschen custom Code heute um deinen dann ein dann eigentlich einander zu fahren soll und wir denken dass du der einzige Weg raus ist weil wir,
auch mehrere Sachen parallel fanden müssen wir brauchen nicht nur einer SSL Implementierungen zu wir brauchen mehrere wir brauchen nicht nur eine was ist ich nur SQL database oder so oder was auch immer die Komponenten sind die Leute haben wollen sie Wochen mehrere davon,
und die sollten möglichst beschränkt sondern sollten mixed Teams sein die sich darauf genau konzentrieren dass dieses Stück Software so sicher wie möglich ist,
unperformant implementiert wird und kompatibel gehört nur zum Rest des Pudels und daraus entsteht dann halt eben noch die Möglichkeit Sonderförderung so zu fahren savski wenn die Hälfte practice Halen ist nicht so schlimm.
Solange die hat die andere Hälfte funktioniert kein Problem so und wenn du halt sagst okay befördert halbrohe 150 und solchen Projekten,
hast du nach 10 Jahren den ganzen Scheiß einfach mal gebaut dann bist du halt einfach,
so dann hast du einfach so die wesentlichen Probleme Abschlag.
Ein Ansatz der bei der dabei auch ausprobiert wurde die haben ja in diesem Server Fast Track Programm,
genau dies Ding gemacht zusagt ok 4 Wochen bis zur Entscheidung maximale Projektor McLovin halbe Millionär was ist maximal Laufzeit 1 Jahr sieht zu was er hin bekommt man einfach so mal,
mixed schnell möglichst möglichst Angela aber eben mit auch einen hohen Sicherheits Anspruch und ich denke das halt genau dieser.
Im dieser Ansatz der richtige ist die man halt dann aber eben doch lange durchhalten muss also man halt doch nicht sagen kann ok,
18 Jahre sind jetzt nur vier Projekte und nie was geworden deswegen schnell was man so muss er vorher seine dauert jetzt einfach 10 Jahre ist halt so müssen halt müssen allgemein fertig werden.
Und dann hättest du zumindest das von von Grund auf instabil bauen mit hoffentlich geringer Komplexität bauen gelöst.
Und du hättest es halt eben doch nachdem Weise gelöst wo ist für die Industrie attraktiv ist die Sachen hat einfach zu verwenden weil wenn er aufsteht.
Die Milliarden spannenden.
Das ist halt ein wie wird halt gepflegt die kann sich darauf verlassen dass es gepflegt wird und Soltau diktiert,
in sich und sprachen geschrieben dass ich an Designkriterien und es gibt zumindest mal so eine Gruppe Interoperabilität zwischen diesen Komponenten,
so hatte man halt am Ende innensystem wo es sehr attraktiv ist es zu benutzen einfach weil danach dungs resigniere zierst,
wasserkino hast hier und Soft westick wo du jetzt nicht dich drauf verlassen muss dass die drei Jungs da um von der Garage in Finnland jetzt noch Bock haben drei eine weiterzumachen.
Hallo da gibt's natürlich lauter Detail Komplexitäten und Leiter der Teilprobleme über die man erlangen,
Kind kann aber zumindest mal zu sagen wir machen das jetzt mal wie für eine politische Entscheidungen und die es gibt halt.
Das die Marschrichtung überhaupt erst.
Also beinhaltet vor allem also erstens dieses Ding auf die Beine zu stellen zweitens natürlich auch schon mal das entscheidende Umdenken eben nicht mehr.
Alte Sachen insofern weiter zu pflegen dass man die neuen nur in kleinen Projekten macht das ist ja das was heute passiert ja das sind im Prinzip gesagt der größere Teil ist schon da wir brauchen nur noch,
obendrauf das zu planschen sowas wie TTP gibt's jetzt seit 25 Jahren wir müssen nur noch ein geiles yurei dafür bauen oder vorher,
sondern wirklich mal zu sagen ok wirklich tabula rasa hier Micro Colonel basierte Architektouren Betriebssystem und dann geht's irgendwie dann geht's geht's voran ja,
ihr unicornis quasi zu sagen ne wir immer wir versuchen die Komplexität zu reduzieren das her.
Im Prinzip der entscheidende anderes sein TV dass ich Betriebssysteme live patchen lassen da operieren die Linux dorther seit längerer Zeit dran.
Können während der Laufzeit patchen.
Harry sind in Linux aus ich meine Systemd ist halt so ein genau der Gegenentwurf zu Entwicklern und überschaubarer deshalb so deswegen denke ich dass daraus ein bisschen so auf das Softwarearchitektur Aerzen.
Das ist das was ich meine was ihm immer mit also wenn Software hinreichend lange gepflegt wurde und immer mehr Anforderungen angesprochen dran angebracht wurden dann fängt irgendwann jemand an wieder eine neue Abstraktionsebene einzuziehen,
das ist irgendwie im Prinzip das nicht,
der Natur die natürliche Reaktion des des ID Softwareprojekte Pflegens und das ist natürlich also ist es in die in einer gewissen Weise genau das ne lass uns mal ne einfache ab 3 Abstraktionsebene wieder dazwischen ziehen.
Die andere Abstraktionsebene verstecken wer dahinter dann sieht das besser aus.
Genau am Inhaber Kühlakku zum Körle.
Aber abstrahiert ja das sind dann irgendwie diese.
Danke dass du auch einen wirklich eine kulturelle Änderung herbeigeführt wenn müssen das wäre natürlich klar wenn das ist würden wir uns ja alle wünschen dass das,
PSI mal da so eine Rolle spielen könnte.
Ich vermute es wird eine an organisation sein müssen wir spsi heute kulturell vielleicht dazu nicht,
die optimal aufgestellt Organisation das aber ja ab das ließe sich ja Regel.
Jetzt können wir noch schon lange quatschen bleib noch eine Sache weil es ja jetzt auch in USA an den in den nächsten Wochen wie lang ist das noch hin bis Velen November Wahlen.
Zwei Wochen drei Wochen.
Die mithören sind ja spannend die nächste die nächste Frustrationen.
Ja also Wahlen darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus.
Haben sich gezeigt sind ein Kerngeschäft dieses neuen Zauber Krieges und das ist offensichtlich geworden in der Wahl,
Kongresswahl oder Präsidentenwahlen vor 2 Jahren USA und eben auch davor wie sich herausgestellt hat man da auch ähnliche Kräfte am Werk,
irgendwann brexit halt hat sich jetzt gezeigt aber in diesem tust benutzt,
sind Twitter Netzwerke haben da Einfluss genommen und das auch schon,
Wein sehr langen Zeitraum im Vorfeld also da ist zurzeit über Jahre hinweg schon langsam vorgearbeitet worden sind einerseits dieser Account aufgebaut worden aber wurde auch Hashtags
so also gerade dieses Lied ist Hashtag.
Reasons to leave you
so das ist schon Jahre vorher irgendwie von so komischen
Account hochgespielt worden wo im nicht wirklich Leute aus mit keine Briten dahinter waren also ist Agenda Setting ist so eine Sonne langsam,
speilbrunn sitzt auch schon noch Rolle.
Genesis Kapitel dazu zu dieser also haben's genannt auf jeden den Angriff auf Gefühle und Gedanken um diese Einordnung.
Von Sau Operationen in das größere ganzer Hals kein bisschen,
mehr auszuführen da sind wir halt auf eine Sache gestoßen das.
Tja Diaz und Weise wie insbesondere die Russen Operation durchgeführt werden,
offensichtlich inspiriert sind
von einer strategischen Überlegungen als sitzen konkretes Ziel zu erreichen sondern erst mal so den Grund zu bauen die den Boden zu legen dafür,
die Fähigkeit der westlichen Gesellschaften halt zum Discos zu Meinungsfindung zur Meinungsbildung komplett zu unterminieren,
und dazu gehört halt es in immer kleinere Lager zu spalten und,
die Strategie dafür ist interessanterweise,
inspiriert davon dass von dem Playbook mit dem so RIAS Berlin und ähnliche,
amerikanische untergallsbach amerikanischer Auslandssender funktioniert haben die halt auch immer über den Osten berichtet haben,
lieber das was da passiert ist und über die Korruption und alles und deren Einflussnahme,
in der Puppe auf der Propaganda Seite nicht so Holz hammermäßig war wie man sonst halt irgendwie so von der Propaganda erkennt,
sondern mir so halt so eine gewisse Grundhaltung verändern so eine Stimmung aufbauen so einfach soll mehr an den Emotionen und dem
Fußgefühl dem Grundgefühl ansetzen,
und nicht so sehr jetzt einfach direkte Propaganda Ziele verfolgen so,
sowie zwischen Story verbergen oder eine Story nach vorne bringen und dieses.
System nachdem halt so diese diese ganzen Sachen von Russia Today arbeiten,
sind halt so ähnlich und die machen eine Sache die die haben ja,
viele kleinere Einheiten abgespalten die jeweils auf bestimmte Zielgruppen zugeschnitten sind nur soll Russia Today ist jetzt halt so zumindest in Deutschland halt mehr so die Fraktion die halt schon immer wusste dass der Staat und wie die Bösen sind und,
dann gibt's aber jetzt zum auch für die Linken gibt's jetzt in Dings costs breadfish,
dr selben Ecke die hat die ihre Propaganda,
Kapazitäten durchaus auch einsetzen für linke Bewegungen und halt einfach die deren Anliegen davor.
Sag mal was ist das wirklich genau also wir wer wäre.
British ist nun ist von hier in Berlin von von Russia Today ruptly gegründet.
Jens the stream.
Genau und ist halt so eine Sonne also quasi genauso Prinzip Zusagen so es gibt halt irgendwie jede Menge berechtigte Themen und ich schieß die Haut und Venen westlichen Medien underreported sind dahin gesichert run.
Und in der Regel ist seit keiner so offensichtliche Russland Propaganda dranne sondern halt eher nur,
Hinweisen auf Themen die halt ja.
Spalten sind also die oder die hatten hohen emotionalen Anteil haben so und dir.
Grundeinkommen Hawaii.
Alles Grundeinkommen Polizeigewalt Protest gegen irgendwie Großkonzerne,
einmal alles so Feminismus so einmal alles vorüber heutzutage suchen,
gut oder sowas hat irgendwie Themen sind Flüchtlinge natürlich Russia Today weil gestängehalter wieso ist das dicke Ding.
Mit dem Ziel ja halt einfach so dieses.
Die Möglichkeit hat man da zu reden hat zuzusetzen und damit halt einfach den,
am Ende auch politische Aktivität zum Erlegen zu bringen das ist halt so uninspiriert ist das ganze halt von dem von dem Präsidenten Berater von Putin Ladislav soccer,
der hat also Kopf genau sagt der,
hat es entwickelt so aus dem postmodern Theater dass er zum Theater Typ eigentlich,
der hat dieses Prinzip dieser Jahr Gelenken demokr,
die in Russland in der Zeit wo mit WDF dran war also zwischen den Beinen Putin,
Eros benutzt um quasi so eine Art Chaos Gefühl zu erzeugen,
Dima halt alle möglichen Gruppe finanziert der hat halt und wie Skinheads nationalistisches Kenneth finanziert und Menschenrechtsgruppen,
Umweltgruppen und Leute die in dieser Woche nach unserer Arbeitsplätze für NPO sein.
Also immer die konträren Interessen finanziert.
Und hatte dann irgendwann durchsickern lassen dass er es tut er hat halt also quasi,
ihr wart leider alle nur die Puppen.
Ihr seid alle nur gekaufte euch.
Genau so und deshalb so und ihren seit einer seiner seiner Methoden gewesen und deshalb so ein bisschen so diese diese Geschichte die.
Ja so diese Russia Today,
Varianten halt jetzt auch machen und zwar,
ihr seid doch schwierig Nase wenn du das niemandem Protest gegen unter sozialer Ungerechtigkeit sonst das Lied ich niemand für dich,
Nadine niemand guckt insoweit und wir alle wollen Facebook klicken oder Instagram oder was auch immer,
dann kommt die vorbei sagen so hey hier wir halten eine Kamera,
wir haben uns wieder in Facebook spiel mit zweieinhalb Millionen Leuten wir bringen dein Anliegen da vorne willst uns ein Interview geben.
Pegida ist ja auch ein gutes Beispiel so.
Und dann hast du halt NW des Problems okay.
Will mein Anliegen voranbringen versus ich weiß das sind die Russen.
Sodowa Konflikt so,
und wenn du halt sagst ok ich schwöre Anliegen voranbringen es mir doch egal wärst und wie publiziert was er liegt über Ansicht ist Nasensauger.
Jochen paar der coolsten brexit Gegner sitzen ist auch bei RTL im Studio.
Die gesagt in denen ist das egal also die machen die wollen halt nur.
Papa gesagt bei uns.
So und die Wahrheit Auseinandersetzung nur sollten sollten möglichst viel Streit geben soll dann ist halt so dieses dieses dieses Ding immer bei den Russen ist steht drauf na das hat nicht so das ist halt ok der Slogan von Russia Today ist question mark,
alles zu fragen,
für uns ist halt doch Salzungen die sind doch nicht so dass sie dir halt ok wirklich ins Gesicht lügen soll alles angehört schon musst halt nur lesen können so.
Zurück und dieser also wir haben halt in dem Buch hat also ja zur Waffe gemacht und Postmodernismus bezeichnet weil halt dieses alles zerlegen alles zur Fragen die die Konstruktionen.
Keiner mehr weiß was überhaupt noch richtig hin.
Genau ist halt meine disappear Bestandteil der Text und balances des westlichen Medien Systems unter der Demokratie das,
Frank stellen kannst dass du den ja den Sachen,
die Interessen dahinter aufdecken kannst du so weiter nur.
Am dieser so weit getrieben ist es am okay interessanterweise entsteht daraus ja nichts Neues oder soll das bleibt heute nur so einfällt des Zweifels und der.
Niemand hat mehr Bock sich da und wir lassen uns auseinanderzusetzen zurück so und deshalb das wohl wo sie hinwollen deshalb solide Ziel.
Permanenzen hosszu.
Bau der permanenten aus Zustand.
Nissan x 30 ausführlich beschrieben was uns wichtig war dass man halt einfach die den den Versuch halt irgendwie sich.
Bisschen zu erklären na gut ich muss auch bald mal los übrig.
Glaube wir haben jetzt auch gerade einen guten Endpunkt gefunden für diese Sendung die weit auch lange noch.
Wie lange wird man Rücksendung für Mama.
Dreiviertelstunde.
Haben wir auch jedesmal geschafft weil jedesmal eine dreiviertel Stunde lang und länger.
Die Zeit dehnt sich halt mal.
Euer Buch ist letzte Woche,
vorletzte Woche erschienen im Moment seid ihr noch so auch auf der auf der Reise durch die Medien und Veranstaltungsorte dieser Welt.
Ja wir machen gerade so ein bisschen promotur was aber auch will,
tatsächlich crissante Gespräche zurückgekommen heute Vermittlungsgespräch die hat einfach nicht verstanden hatten die gerne verstehen wollen,
so gut also natürlich ist ein Großteil von diesen Fragen hat immer so was kann ich denn tun so nah und wär so was ist jetzt so ich als armer Windows-Nutzer habe was kann ich denn machen,
und die Antworten Haus natürlich deprimierender kümmert sich auch nicht wieder ne.
Der Mackintosh.
Ich habe eure Termine stehen auf der Verlagsseite ne bei Random House.
Ja wir machen wir haben auch einen Twitter-Account Cyberwar Buch also at,
genau wo war die Idee Termine jeweils dazu tun hast klar dann vielen Dank.
Wir danken dir Frank und wünsche dir noch einen schönen Cyberwar ist ja Freitag und tim hast du schöne chapter marks gemacht.
Ja klar vielleicht.
Sieht aber ein bisschen mager aus ehrlich gesagt.
Habe ich noch mal.
Gouda musst du noch mal bei unter 56.
Du ja auch ne.
Du das alles hier ich will leben ist hiermit episoden Bildern und so ne.
Da hat er da hat der homepod tatsächlich sehr gut vorgelegt muss ich sagen da bin ich mal gespannt.
Taff Geschichte Update.
Adresse hinkriegt aber wir sind ja heute auch,
1200 m in den Cyberwar ein gefeiert.
Absolut gut dann wünsche euch noch viel Spaß wir sehen und hören uns dann in Wien so ihr denn dort vor,
Ort sein werdet wenn nicht kriegt er dann die Aufzeichnung wie immer direkt aus Hörgerät.